Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Das war's für heute.
Aber ich hab mal geguckt, Amazon Tablets sind anscheinend bedrohter.
Wenn man nämlich hier nachguckt, es kommt relativ häufig vor
Ups
Es kommt relativ häufig vor
Das ist meine das ist ja nicht komplett nicht von ungefähr dass es so viele einträge gibt und
Die schreiben halt es liegt daran dass entweder der akku kaputt geht oder dass
irgendwelche
Notification sounds nicht gemuted sind also ich habe alles geguckt ich hab nix gefunden jetzt gemacht habe ich auch das tablet ausgeschaltet
Das chinesen botnet
Das schien das china chinesen wohl vielleicht vielleicht und wenn man halt sagen muss ich benutze darauf eigentlich nur
browser mit
eingebaut im ad blocker entgooglifiziert und alles möglich also ich glaube so den so den großen angriffsvektor
hat mein tablet nicht
Gut aber ich meine im endeffekt es sagt eh das feier tablet also ich habe ich habe mir das ganz billige mal gekauft für 50 euro
So eins
mal sieben ist das billige ne
Dann habe ich einen achter gekauft
Man muss immer warten bis es die hälfte kostet für 50 euro irgendwie reduziert
Und das ist halt das ist halt schon ein ziemliches crap tablet ich meine das ist preisleistungsmäßig das beste android tablet was es gibt aber
Es ist halt es ist halt im vergleich zu anderen tablets müll dazu kommt dass es relativ wenige gescheite android tablets gibt
Und peepen für den akku kaputt wäre richtig bescheuert weiß ich weiß bloß was die leute in einem forum geschrieben haben
Guck hier
So nach dem motto batterie ist fast leer ich piepst noch mal dass die batterie schneller
schneller leer geht also man findet total viel zu amazon feier und und feier tablet und so piepst und sowas
So und was ich jetzt mache ist
Ich kaufe mir einfach ein ipad
Ich bin ja wie gesagt was tablets angeht kein großartige android fan ich meine ich habe genug ausprobiert
Ich habe mittlerweile an die elf android tablets am start und irgendwie gefällt mir keines davon richtig gut gut das war jetzt auch
Da waren jetzt bis auf eins auch keine höherpreisigen geräte dabei das war
Das eine war beispielsweise
Ein werbegeschenk damals dann sind zwei schild schild tablets die eigentlich ganz gut sind aber die schild tablets haben komplett ihre akku power schon
verloren die sind zu alt
Dann sind zwei zwei feier hd 10 die funktionen tatsächlich gut als dashboards für meine heimautomatisierung
Dann habe ich so ein altes tecranote das sagt dass es das ist schon komplett komplett
Kannst schon komplett knicken dann ein asus dann habe ich mir einmal gedacht ich kaufe mir halbwegs gescheites
Android tablet habe ich mir vor drei vier jahren gekauft und dann hat asus gesagt ach nee
Gebaited wir stellen einfach einen monat nachdem du es gekauft hast den support ein
So und dann habe ich mir gedacht okay ich habe jetzt so viele tablets da am start gehabt kein problem und ich habe hier für meine mutter schon vor
Drei jahren oder so ein ipad gekauft habe das noch ein iphone ipad 5
oder so das gibt es da generations
Gibt es für ipad generations zeit mal her
Ich glaube
Das ist zu neu ich vermute mal das hier aber es bekommt noch es bekommt noch updates das weiß ich
Ja gut da muss es das hier sein wenn das ist ja ja fifth generation ipad das bekommt nämlich noch das bekommt nämlich noch
updates das heißt
Das müsste das müsste das sein
So zumindest
Habe ich ja das gekauft vor vor hier wahrscheinlich drei jahren oder so
oder dreieinhalb jahren und ich muss echt sagen ich benutze das auch manchmal ich finde das vollkommen in ordnung ja
also besser als alle android tablets die ich bisher hatte
Bei smartphones kann man sich vielleicht noch drum streiten aber ganz ehrlich so im tablet bereich
Hat mich nichts überzeugt das ipad ist das beste hat natürlich auch ein paar nachteile wie gesagt es hat alles irgendwo seine vornachteile
beispielsweise hat
ipad halt so diese typischen apple geschichten so nach dem motto du musst das halt unseren weg machen oder gar nicht
zum beispiel was du halt bei apple nicht machen kannst ist dass du
automatisch notifications öffnen ist und sowas das ist natürlich normalerweise auch sinnvoll keine notifications
zu öffnen ja also für den normalen 0815 benutzer ist das schon sinnvoll du willst ja nicht dass irgendeine
website notifications macht oder in irgendeine app amok läuft notifications macht automatisch
Dinger öffnet links öffnen sonst was klar das willst du nicht aber zum beispiel wo man das will ist
wenn man eine app hat von seiner kamera am hoftor
und will zum beispiel dass es nach einem klick oder am besten gar keinen klick automatisch aufgeht das ist was das kannst du unter android halt easy machen
mit tasker oder irgendwelche anderen scripting zeug es ist hoffnungslos
außer du hast vielleicht ein gejailbreak des ipad eventuell
das mit einem ios zu machen geht halt einfach nicht
so übrigens haben die nicht demnächst hier apple spring event spring loaded genau
what to a the verge war mal war the verge nicht das mit diesem tollen mit diesem mit dieser tollen anleitung zum pc bauen
die die haben ja ahnung ja
Am 20.04 ist quasi wie die ubuntu version am 20.04 ist das apple event okay das apple event ist genau
am gleichen datum wie der name der aktuellen ubuntu lts version ich vermute da irgendwelche
Verschwörungstheorie
So was vermuten sie denn ipad pro aber ich muss mal kurz
Leute achtung flash bang flash bang die seite klappt mit dark wieder wobei ich es ist früh ich ich flash bang euch nicht aber ich muss mal kurz
Okay, die seite kann man gar nicht da dann doch die sieht sogar relativ gut aus also was ipad pro die die dinger sind halt viel zu teuer
Das sehe ich das sehe ich nicht ein was denke ich der unterschied zwischen einem eher und einem normalen ipad außer dass es doppelte kostet
und wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen teuer ist also ich glaube das ist ein bisschen teuer
Aber nicht dass mich das gewicht großartig schocken würde von dem ipad
So okay apple die apple seite funktioniert nicht mit dem hintergrund
Oh guck mal apple ist ultra lazy beim webdesign das ist einfach ein bild das ist einfach ein bild mit der gleichen hintergrundfarbe das ist noch nicht mal transparentes bild
keck wait apple keck wait
So nicht mal transparentes bild das ist einfach ein bild mit der hintergrundfarbe von der webseite das ist ja billig apple
Da hätte ich da hätte ich jetzt von apple mehr erwartet
So der scheiß ist halt ultra teuer ne die ipad pro ist mal guckst
Das er unterstützt die zweite generation apple pencils, okay das brauche ich nicht
Es juckt mich nicht so also ich will auf jeden fall ein 11 zoll display ganz ehrlich mir wäre sogar noch ein kleineres display lieber ich benutze das nur abends im bett um noch ein bisschen youtube und streams zu gucken und zwischendurch mal draufzuschauen
Was hat denn das ipad also ich vermute mal dass wir das ipad pro haben und ich glaube wir haben das ipad pro schon mal ein bisschen verpasst
Also ich vermute mal dass meine mutter das ipad das fünfte oder sechste generation hat was haben die was haben die für eine größe
Was haben die für eine display größe
9,7
9,7 okay es hat auf jeden fall 9,7
Ja das ist mir eigentlich schon fast ein ticken zu groß gewesen wenn ich da im bett zum streams gucken aber es gibt halt nichts kleineres als 11 in dem fall
Was natürlich cool ist haben die haben die face id
Warte mal kann man kann auch irgendwie vergleichen ipad vergleichen moment muss mal gucken was hat denn face id was hat denn face id
Das finde ich nämlich eine coole coole geschichte wo bleak okay was kann man vergleichen ipad pro
Moment warum ist das vierte generation und dass das ist zweite vierte
Apple
Was das ist doch im prinzip genau das gleiche wie die ipad pro
Hä Apple was das ist doch im Prinzip genau das gleiche nur mit kleinerem kleinerem display oder
Monkeys also kriegt doch keiner durch
Ok
Face was hat face id das hat face nicht face all die fäden immer das face time
das hat face an nur die pros haben face all die mein face all die ist schon nice ja ich habe das
auch nie verwendet weil ich immer gesagt habe alle passwort beste aber ich muss sagen auf
meinem iphone ist face all die tatsächlich ganz nice das ist überhaupt ein unterschied
dazwischen zwischen den zwei genau das genau das gleiche ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt für
eine terabyte muss ich dann erstmal 800 euro plus bezahlen oder so nee apple ganz sicher ganz sicher
warum kostet das ach so das ist das dass ich habe es verkehrt rum sortiert aber das ist doch
genau das gleiche warum ist das eine zweite generation und das andere vierte generation
vielleicht ist das zweite generation vom 11 zoll ipad pro ok die benahmung ist aber beknackt
normalerweise nennst du ja die hardware generation und dann wenn es display unterschiedlich groß
ist meinetwegen aber trotzdem ok apple na gut apple macht das schon gut apple macht das schon
gut weil die leute denken sich ach komm für für für keine ahnung für ach komm für 200 euro für
150 euro mehr kriege ich quasi schon vierte generation das ist eigentlich richtig 6 hat
was machst du gerade ich gucke gerade ein neues ipad kaufen da kommt man ein paar videos an
ipad er 22 real ipad pro killer gut aber ipad er hat kein hat kein face all die face all die
fände ich schon ziemlich cool schreibt man das face all die also ganz ehrlich face all die wäre
das einzige warum ich mir einen ipad kaufen würde was kein normales ipad für 379 euro ist wobei mal
ganz im ernst ich sehe es nicht ein für face all die das doppelte zu bezahlen das ist halt echt
lull ansonsten was ansonsten war ganz im ernst was ist da was ist der unterschied gibt doch
eigentlich kein großartigen das hier ist mir sogar lieber zehn monat lang schön exquisite
subscription hier also das ist mir sogar lieber von der größe kann man mal bitte jemand die katze
über uns nee warum die muss da bleiben die sitzt ja noch nicht mal im weg ist die beobachtet den
chat dass der chat kein scheiß baut gut also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist die abmaße
ungefähr gleich ja gehe ich auch mal von aus aber das stört mich nicht 12 12,2 10,2 zoll reicht mir
auch dicke so das macht wahrscheinlich absolut keinen unterschied in dem was man täglich damit
macht ob das jetzt in a 12 z oder a 12 ist und das hier sind a 14 warum hat das pro denn
bitteschön älteren prozessor als das andere wahrscheinlich weil das ich blinke ich nicht
durch das alles in ordnung reicht mir dicke ich nehme die 32 g variante wozu braucht man mehr
die wissen schon genau warum die keine micro sd karte da drin einbauen reicht mir auch dicke
ob es in lightning anschluss oder nicht ist juckt mich persönlich jetzt nicht großartig usb c wäre
mir lieber aber ich habe genug von allem jetzt gibt er die vermutung dass die ein neues ipad
pro hier vorstellen schreiben sie auch hier neues ipad pro aber das ist erstmal wahrscheinlich
schwer zu bekommen und kostet zu viel also ganz ehrlich ich sehe keinen vorteil für mich dass
da fürs doppelte zu kaufen anstatt das da ich meine es kostet einfach das doppelte das ist es
das ist außer wenn man also außer wenn man stiftstellen machen will ist das so eigentlich
gar nicht wert das juckt mich halt auch nicht wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich kaufe ich mir
einfach dass da ich warte mal das apple event ab weil vielleicht werden die dinger irgendwie
billiger nach dem apple event war wobei keck weight jetzt habe ich mich selbst gebadet als
würde das irgendwie billiger werden da gibt es höchstens eine neue version die dann irgendwie
noch mal 100 euro mehr kostet ja mal gucken ich glaube auch dass die eher teurer werden
so was stellen sie dann noch vor ipad pro wird vermutet dass sie vorstellen ok apple pencil 3
juckt mich jetzt persönlich gar nicht ipad mit ach so was da jetzt der unterschied zwischen
ipad mini fünfte generation das ok das ist eigentlich eine schöne größe die gefällt
mir ehrlich gesagt warum ist das eigentlich kleiner und teurer obwohl die gleiche hardware
drin ist also mehr oder weniger stonks also wirklich wirklich wirklich erkennen tut man
das nicht warum das apple logik halt ipad mini ist jetzt so klar ich finde das gerade gut
ganz ehrlich ich finde sogar ich finde ich fand ich fand das alte diese 9,7 zoll was
ich meiner mutter gekauft habe sogar schon zu groß also das ist eigentlich für mich
ist das hier richtig schneise größe wahrscheinlich kaufe ich das wahrscheinlich kaufe ich wieder
ganz normal das 379 euro gut ist übrigens man wird übelst gebadet wenn man sich übelst
gebadet wenn man sich ein ipad kauft ich habe damals auch den fehler gemacht also wenn man
hier was weiß ich bla bla bla so und hier und hier kommt das gebadet das ist eigentlich
big brain von apple massive gebadet wenn du sagst keine gravur ist alles ok aber wenn
du sagst hups wenn du sagst gravur also hier keck weiht so und sobald du sobald du gravur
hast kannst du es nicht mal zurückgeben weil es für dich personalisiert ist eigentlich
eigentlich massive brain von apple das kostenlos anzubieten die leute denke ich oh cool kostenlose
gravur null tja gebadet da ist nichts mehr mit zurückgeben wenn es gravierend gravieren
lassen hast eigentlich eigentlich richtig clever von apple das zu machen tipp für ein
günstiges tablet für meine eltern ja ein ipad das da schlag dich da gerade für die
eltern auch selbst wenn die nicht so technikalisiert sind es gibt eigentlich kein vergleichbares
android tablet was preismäßig und und komfortmäßig für die etwas ältere generation so gut funktioniert
aber bei smartphones kann man sich drum streiten aber ich finde gerade wenn man ein tablet
für die eltern kauft ist das ipad das beste was man kann es sei denn du hast irgendwelche
anwendungszwecke die halt nicht gehen mit einem ipad dann dann kannst du den android
kaufen aber ansonsten ganz ehrlich würde ich das kaufen 379 ist auch echt preisleistungsmäßig
ganz gut hätte ich gar nicht mal gedacht dass apple das ding am start hat was preisleistungsmäßig
mir auch am besten gefällt alles matze nee das hast du nicht wenn du das bestellst wenn
du das markierst und bestellst das ich versuche das jetzt mal ob das ob man das irgendwie
ane ich muss erst mal bezahlen die sagen dir dann auch beim bestellvorgang wenn es custom
für dich graviert wird musst du zustimmen dass es quasi so eine maßanfertigung für
dich ist und du deswegen darauf verzichtest auf dein auf dein rückgaberecht steht natürlich
alles nicht dabei kann man gucken ipad gravur rückgabe kekwad
das schreiben die auch das schreiben die auch wenn du bestellst jaja man muss man muss
zustimmen also das kann man apple da in dem fall gar nicht vorwerfen ganz ehrlich ich
verstehe das auch dass man keine gravierten geräte zurücknehmen will aber dass sie diesen
kostenlose gravur anbieten liegt meiner meinung nach eindeutig daran dass man das eben nicht
mehr zurückgeben kann das ist ich verstehe es auf der einen seite dass man es nicht
zurücknimmt auf der anderen seite ist es halt meiner meinung nach eindeutig den five
hat trick move dass man es nicht zurück 32g reicht ja ja also ich weiß ich weiß nicht
ob es euch reicht aber ich bin noch nie über den chat mal frage euch seid ihr irgendwie
mal an die an die größen grenzen von eurem tablet gestoßen ich nehme immer nur das kleinste
also in dem fall 32g das reicht dicke ich habe da überhaupt gar keine probleme zumal
wenn man da ich speichere sogar die ein oder anderen videos fotos und sonstige sachen drauf
selbst wenn man das macht und es wird zu voll dann ist der größte teil des speichers immer
noch videos beziehungsweise fotos und die kann man auch woanders haben die muss man
ja nicht permanent auf dem tablet oder auf dem smartphone mit sich rumtragen aber selbst
da man kommt eigentlich nicht an die grenzen ich weiß nicht ob einer von euch schon mal
geschafft hat sein tablet voll zu machen ne also ja gut es gibt immer low brain leute
ja man muss ja nicht in der cloud speichern man kann es auch bei sich auf dem fileserver
oder sonst wo speichern überhaupt kein problem ok 16g ist vielleicht echt ein bisschen klein
das stimmt aber selbst 16g wird wahrscheinlich auskommen der sebaro ist da und sebaro ist
das ist das klicks hormon level immer noch oben stonks ja gut wenn man wenn man viel
musik speichern will auf dem gerät dann verstehe ich das aber muss ich halt überlegen es ist
halt verdammt teuer speicher ne guckt euch das mal an also speicher ist halt viel zu
teuer selbst beim normalen ipad so kaufen guck mal die wollen allen ernstes die wollen allen
ernstes von 32 kammer das kann man nicht besser die wollen allen ernst von 32 100 euro mehr
ist ihr was das kostet das kostet nix normalerweise nix das ist das ist paar euro was das kost
ich meine die machen das ja schon clever die machen das insofern schon clever die schreiben
32g und schreiben 128 gehen weil da sagen die leute im kopf das ist ja viermal mehr
das ist natürlich gerechtfertigt dass das 100 euro ist ist es aber nicht das scheiß
ist viel viel zu teuer 100 euro guck mal ihr kriegt für den preis 100 euro komm ich guck
mal was es für eine ssd gibt mit 100 euro 500g 500g ssd so guck mal 500g ssd 500g ssd
kost nur 57 euro so also wir können sogar eine terabyte ssd kaufen quasi für den preis
sogar günstiger als wo dir apple 100g gibt also sprich das ist selbst wenn es jetzt erst
mal auf den ersten blick clever gemacht ist weil apple ja big brain ist mit mit diesen
staffelungen dass du immer denkst ah das geht noch ah das geht noch ah das geht noch ist
das schwachsinnig ist total schwachsinnig und das ist auch der grund warum die keine
mikro sd karten dinger einbauen stellt euch mal vor wie viele leute würden ernsthaft
das speicher upgrade kaufen wenn man da sd karten oder mikro sd karten rein machen könnte
selbst wenn man eine wirklich gute mikro sd karte nimmt die die kostet die kostet ein
bisschen mehr und die mag vielleicht nicht so gut sein wie der flash der da drinnen
ist aber für die musik zum speichern das vollkommen ausreichend und es hat den vorteil
man könnte theoretisch sogar mehrere mikro sd karten mitnehmen und immer das rein machen
was man gerade braucht also das hat schon seinen grund und eigentlich ist es ziemlich
user unfreundlich dass man keinen sd karten leser ich weiß gar nicht gibt es gibt es
fürs ipad ein mikro sd kart reader so irgendwas für lightning oder so kann man das kann man
das an ipad machen ja gut guckt aber hier also klar also das kann man natürlich machen
es sieht halt ein bisschen scheiße aus wenn das da auch noch so raus raus pimmelt ja keine
ahnung aber es funs also es ist auf jeden fall die preislich bessere investition als
das abzukrennen die sache ist nur die dadurch dass die ja mittlerweile auch so extrem beschränkt
sind was schrittstellen angeht und du hast ja kein was ja kein klinkenstecker mehr das
heißt wenn nicht grad wenn ich grad bluetooth kopfhörer hast kannst du halt kein mikro
sd karte rein machen und gleichzeitig kopfhörer anschließen was hier eh nur noch mit so einem
komischen dongel geht dann musst du dir wieder in so ein multifunktionsgerät den kaufen was
das alles in einem hat also user freundlich ist es nicht apple weiß das auch und deswegen
bietet apple für 100 euro einen speicher upgrade an was eigentlich viel viel viel viel viel
zu teuer ist und machen kein mikro sd karten rein naja usb c kann man nicht an diese lightning
anschlüsse stecken ich glaube reinpassen tut das nicht aber ich also lademäßig gibt es
auf jeden fall adapter wie starten mäßig aussieht ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ach guck mal gibt
gibt sogar von apple fertige dinger das ist natürlich wahrscheinlich viel zu teuer
warum wollen wir das ist das ist das ist echt apple apple logik dass es so teuer ist war
der mal apple lightning to usb der speicher in der höheren variante ist meistens auch
schneller ja selbst wenn das ist überhaupt wirst du nicht merken und apple please
sind die noch ganz sind die noch irgendwie ach so ok das ist ja aber trotzdem hallo 40
euro was ist denn das hdmi oder es ist usb c usb c und und was was ist das linke normaler
usb oder was ist das ist das links normaler usb und das rechten usb 10 man erkennt ja
nicht mal richtig können mal richtige photos machen oder es ist eine sd karte links ah hier
sd das links in sd karten leser und das rechte usb c das heißt dann hast du richtig krasses
dongle live ich habe irgendwas im hals von ks so meine güte aber das ist echt wieder
krass überzogener preis bei apple aber sind wir ja gewohnt ist ja nichts neues ist ja
nichts neues exzellent so jetzt haben wir uns lang genug damit beschäftigt chat habe
ich irgendwas übersehen ja genau das können die aber echt gut also apple schafft das
wirklich dich von einem 379 euro ipad zu einem 1200 euro ipad zu gbaken und du freust dich
dann auch noch darüber dass du es bezahlen darfst
kann man machen ja wobei sd karten halt unverhältnismäßig teurer werden ab einer gewissen größe was
ist denn so die größte mikro sd die es gibt ein terabyte oder so zwei gibt es gibt schon
zwei terabyte hier oder ane ein terabyte ein terabyte das ist aber halt auch unverhältnismäßig
teuer da kram aber gut es gibt es gibt es ich wüsste jetzt so spontan nicht außer
ich würde ganz viele filme machen mit meiner kamera oder so wofür ich mir unbedingt eine
terabyte mikro sd kaufen müsste da würde ich lieber preisleistungsmäßig 128 g oder
256 g nehmen und austauschen ja vielleicht sogar 128 besser ja 128 preisleistungsmäßig
deutlich besser guck mal 128 g ist so der sweet spot wahrscheinlich was mikro sd karten
preise und größen angeht ja ok ich glaube ich habe nichts übersehen das meta pad was
ist das denn ach nee nicht meta mate mate pad nicht meta pad wie lang gibt es updates
ästliche hintergrund gut nicht das ist jetzt schlimmer also ein klinke stecker haben die
noch ein klinke stecker zeigen sie ja nicht von vorne komische überstehende kamera
haben die noch einen klinke stecker wahrscheinlich ja noch kopfhörer doch die haben noch die
haben noch klinke stecker exzellent na gut so ich glaube ich habe nix was wie teuer bist
du willst du wissen wieviel subs ich habe wir können nachher eine runde subscriber raten
gibt es tablets außer ipads die was taugen naja wie gesagt ich habe jede menge tablets
hier schon durchprobiert aber das war halt alles auch keine hochpreisigen android tablets
die haben mir alle nicht gefallen und ich finde das ipad eigentlich immer noch am besten
aber es gibt sicherlich auch ipads die man sich geben kann gibt es sicherlich auch tablets
die man sich geben kann als android tablets aber ich kenne bisher keins exquisite subscription
hier wieder video zum ipad eher naja das gucke ich mal an ich warte mal ich warte mal ab
was apple bei ihrem event vorstellt und dann gucke ich mal was ich kauf ok ich habe nix
zu übersehen exquisite der pretzelsnacker zwei monate dankeschön für den sub big brain
subscription hier ja bist du in siebaro pepo fett so also was gucken wir uns jetzt ein
paar runde rat paar runde youtube videos also was haben wir denn hier doom on a commercial
kitchen appliances ist mir jetzt zu lang oh komm leute wir lassen uns jibaden wir lassen
uns wieder jibaden von level cap der sagt hast du das neueste simplicissimus video nee
aber ich das kann sogar sein dass ich das offen habe ach das da das habe ich tatsächlich
offen hier guck da wobei ich wobei ich das mit dem logo design auch echt failed also
ich finde auch das firefox logo design finde ich auch fail die hatten mal ich glaube das
hat er doch hier im thumbnail drinne genau war jetzt einfach den firefox trick dafür
ist firefox tatsächlich ganz gut firefox autoplay videos nämlich nicht wenn man sich das firefox
autoplay videos nicht firefox played autoplay videos nicht warum hat firefox eben das video
autoplay was soll das excellent wenn man sich thumbnails angucken will ist firefox eigentlich
am besten weil er startet das video nicht also das ist bei der gar nicht das aktuelle firefox
logo also das aktuelle firefox logo ist das da aber die entwicklung die entwicklung hier
ist abzusehen ja ich glaube das ist firefox surf android oder wie das ding heißt firefox
android logo ich glaube falls das überhaupt eins ist könnte auch das company logo sein
ich weiß es gar nicht mozilla ja das ist die mozilla logo genau zumindest zumindest
der trend ist der trend der trend ist klar und da ist es nicht das ein da sind es nicht
die einzigen die diesen trend verfolgen mit icons gucken wir uns auch gleich an ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich fand das 2017 logo am besten das 2017 logo war war finde ich die beste
mischung aus so diesem klassischen firefox logo das sei ja früher das sei ja früher
noch noch anders aus firefox browser 0 punkt irgendwie 6 oder so das war noch zu zeit muss
firebird hieß ja naja und ich muss sagen das 2017 logo gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt am besten
das ist auch das ist auch noch finde ich vor den farben herr schosser das ist das ist dunkles
blau und an das firefox schon dazu das neue ist so es ist halt so dass also so logo im
aktuellen logo zeitgeist irgendwie da versucht man mehr so weiche so weiche sanfte farbverläufe
und nicht so viele unterschiede zu haben und sowas das sieht man da sieht man bei vielen
logos wenn man hier durchguckt ok außer bei microsoft die können es mit logos gar nicht
nutzt überhaupt noch jemand firefox ja ich verwende unter den uns als default browser
aber ich habe immer weniger grund für
also mit was
genau du musst die logos skalierbaren können und es ist natürlich auch da sicherlich also
denke ich mal zumindest ich kenne ja keine usability studien oder sonst was zu weil die
user das besser finden also gerade die noob user finden das sicherlich besser wenn das
irgendwie so weiß ich so so modern und und wenn das logo schon nach wenig komplexität
aussieht verbinden die leute damit wahrscheinlich auch eine software die sich gut verwenden
verwenden lassen wird könnte ich mir vorstellen so also was können wir uns heute angucken
doom on a commercial kitchen appliance wir lassen uns nein wir lassen uns jetzt jebaiten
leute wir lassen uns jebaiten von von level cap und lassen jetzt genau uns 30 sekunden
was über das neue battlefield erzählen was absolut nicht gesichert ist und total nicht
sagen ist und dann andere dinger und wir haben uns wieder jebaiten lassen das video zu gucken
welchen browser kann man für auto normal doof empfehlen einfach chrome gut ist firefox
kannst du auch verwenden das ist kein ding also das geht eigentlich beides ohne probleme
aber ich glaube firefox hat mittlerweile wieviel 70 prozent share oder 80 prozent oder
so wir lassen uns erstmal jebaiten hey guys level cap hier und was geht leaks about battlefield
sixes trailer hits social media übrigens ich glaube auch dass demnächst in battlefield
sechs trailer kommt allein schon wenn die das wirklich ende des jahres releaseen wollen
die werden das wahrscheinlich entweder vor call of duty oder so in dem dreh releaseen
wollen wenn es nach denen geht eventuell wahrscheinlich also ich denke mal dass ich wahrscheinlich
sogar einen monat vorher releaseen wollen so ein bisschen schiss haben sie aber die müssen
es ja langsam mal release und es gibt dieses jahr keine großartigen messen in das korona
stellt ich weiß gar nicht wie es mit der e3 dieses jahr aussieht außerdem ist die
ein bisschen spät oder wobei nie verwechsel ich das jetzt wann ist die e3 normalerweise
uni ja das ist ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen spät ja und e3 online messen online jucken
kein mensch hast du auch bei der gamescom gesehen generell ich glaube die letzten zwei
also dieses und das letzte jahr korona hat dazu beigetragen dass man mal gesehen hat
wie unbedeutend computerspiele messen eigentlich sind die braucht niemand auch diese ganzen
anderen messen die es gibt jetzt war doch letztens in barcelona erst eine wie heißt die in
barcelona mobile mobile mobile world ist auch einige von den großen herstellern nicht
hingefahren und so wird immer weiter gehen ich glaube dieses die letzten zwei jahre haben
gezeigt wie unsinnig eigentlich messen sind zumal dieses jetzt mittlerweile eh mehr oder
weniger machen wie apple mit ihren events die kündigen einfach die sachen an wenn sie
so weit sind aber nicht dass zu trotz die müssen ja langsam mal was zeigen also es
bleibt ihnen gar nichts anderes übrig die können es ja schlecht im august zeigen und
dann im september oder oktober releasen können wir schon machen werden sie aber nicht machen
weil die brauchen ja ein paar monate zeit um auch so den das passend die leute auf das
passende halblevel zu bringen dass vielleicht die leute immer noch blöd genug sind sich
die sache vorzubestellen die gamescom war letztes jahr auch online hat es irgendjemand
von euch mitbekommen dass die gamescom online war also beziehungsweise haben online so ein
paar steams gemacht ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal mitbekommen wann das überhaupt
ist ich wusste noch also ich habe im vorfeld drüber gelesen dass sie das machen und ich
habe danach im stream aber mal geschaut ein jahr später haben die das denn jetzt eigentlich
gemacht so ein jahr später passt ja nicht so lange aber ein paar monate später haben
sie das überhaupt gemacht und es hat keine sau gejuckt aber es ist genauso genauso witzlos
aber wisst ihr wisst ihr was die der fehlste deutsche so so computer live stream immer
noch ist das ist dieser komische computerspiel preis das ist so unbedeutend und und langweilig
und unspektakulär und dumm einfach nur dass ich habe das noch nie noch nie geguckt ich
habe immer mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen gucken hat mir dann gedacht ok schön dass
du es nicht geguckt hast ach war der erst wieder ach war der erst wieder wusste ich
gar nicht dass der war war der wieder computer spiele preis 2021 ok das wusste ich gar
nicht dass das war siehst du mal so so gut kriege ich das mit
wer hat gewonnen die gewinner cloud punk das habe ich das wurden wir mal auf stream empfohlen
des mirandos 3 ich kenne nur den ersten der war richtig gut ist aber auch schon 15 jahre
alt oder so immer ist es jetzt von 2021 ja ok kenne ich nicht sagt mir auch nix welten
der werkstoffe ok last of last of us ist definitiv kein deutsches game animal crossing
warum genau gewinnt animal crossing das aber auch kein deutsches game
dorf romantik ok also halten wir mal fest mir sagt kein spiel war es außer die beiden
internationalen spiele die aus welchen gründen auch immer gewonnen haben
spiele in dieser ori und flight simulator ok jetzt mal ernsthaft nach welchen maßstäben
sind sind die sind die bitteschön ausgewählt ich meine randomer kannst du doch spiele
nicht auswählen last of us 2 flight simulator und ori what the fuck was was was was ist
das überhaupt für eine das passt aber das ist doch ok was auch immer ok wisst ihr was
die haben wahrscheinlich einfach bekannte spiele genommen dass sie irgendwie ein bisschen
ein bisschen klemmer haben so was hat denn sonst gewonnen animal crossing ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ist das nicht dass ich das jetzt durcheinander bringe ist das nicht dieses ubisoft battle
royal was übelst gefloppt ist ja ha ha ha ha ha ha eraser ich fasse es net oder ob
ihr das überhaupt harmonie one bestes internationales multiplayer spiel encounters begitu solid
Multiplayer spiel sein
So gelacht dieser preis ist ja komplett sinnlos
Okay, warum sind die nominiert okay, zeig mal her
Das ist eine online Nintendo online spiele gewinnt bestes multiplayer
Ist ja genial
Okay, gibt es da irgendwie den grund warum was daran so herausragend ist
Nede oder
Ja
Grausam gibt es da irgendwie eine begründung warum
Also weshalb hat es gewonnen
Ja das ist doch eher deswegen hat es gewonnen das ist doch eher so nen so nen
Nintendo marketing text was da steht
Letztes jahr hat witcher 3 für die switch ernsthaft
Wirklich das ist ein witz oder moment moment moment das ist ein witz witcher 3 für die switch das kann nicht sein
Anno das verstehe ich ohne scheiß anno ist eines der wenigen spiele von hier wo ich echt sagen könne ja nice das hat auf jeden fall verdient
Also anno gehe ich vollkommen mit rest sagt mir sagt mir nix
Moment weiter dieses jahr nicht auch schon apex legends ja okay meine was zum ernsthaft
Ich habe drei für die switch im jahr 2020 also was ist das was für
Was ist das bitteschön für einen publikumspreis da frage ich mich mein welches publikum haben die denn da bitteschön
Desperados den dritten kenne ich nicht aber der erste war echt gut das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass dies verdient haben was
Ist was ist das ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was ich schlechter finde dass also
Dass die so ein publikum haben die sowas wählen oder dass sowas da überhaupt warum ist auf der switch
Moment ne hat auch mit der switch gar nichts zu tun es ist einfach nur es ist einfach nur das moment moment das hat doch mit der switch gar nichts
zu tun
Das ist einfach nur witcher 3 hat es gewonnen okay warum ganz ehrlich warum wir ja
2020 witcher 3 in den preis gewinnt okay das spiel ist eine moin für nintendo switch da steht es doch
Was
Was ist das für einen null preis alda das ist doch lächerlich
Das doch das kann doch nicht in ernst sein
Aber da muss du jetzt keine wagen okay, okay, gott auf war
Meine güte das ist das ist so eine witzveranstaltung
Dafür hatten sie hübsche influenza rinnen die den die das moderiert haben okay wer hat das moderiert kennt man, kennt man die
hyperscape all das sowas moderiert überhaupt
nominiert ist
Also aber das schockt mich immer noch also da könnte ich mich wann war der denn
Wann war der denn
Vor vier tagen ernsthaft
Wann war der denn vor vier tagen ernsthaft
Ach nee nee das doch doch
Das war ernsthaft es war erst
Das das das das das war das war erst am
Am dienstag ich meine ernsthaft jetzt mal ganz ohne spaß
animal crossing als bestes hätten die das meinetwegen als meinetwegen noch als bestes spiel
Gut da kann man sich sicherlich darüber streiten aber es mögen viele
Aber ausgerechnet als bestes multiplayer spiel es ist ein fucking nintendo online spiel wo die helfe dann funktioniert
Wo du beispielsweise die lobby nicht richtig verlassen kannst du nie speichern kannst wenn ein anderer in deinem spiel drin ist das ist der typische
nintendo kack ja
animal crossing online und warum gewinnt ausgerechnet dieses game was vielleicht ein gutes spiel ist aber
Absolut mieses multiplayer game ist warum gewinnt das bestes internationales multiplayer spiel
Bestes internationales multiplayer spiel
Gut ok scheiß drauf weiter wir lassen uns jetzt von level capture bähnen
Stimmt warte mal ist das überhaupt 2021 erschien animal crossing
Das kam das nicht schon letztes jahr raus
Moment das was das kam auch noch vor genau einem jahr aus
Oh man ich bin fassungslos ok das kommt raus das kommt raus wenn
Irgendwelche ich weiß nicht wer wer wer richtet wer richtet das ding überhaupt aus
irgendwelche irgendwelche komischen irgendwelche komischen fähnchen
Das ist ja auch ein fähnchen
Wer richtet das ding überhaupt aus irgendwelche irgendwelche komischen irgendwelche komischen verbände oder so ja
ok ja das kommt davon wenn irgendwelche ämter
hippe preise kreieren wollen
die von t讓 keine ahnung haben und irgendwelche sachen nominieren die
Es eigentlich nicht verdient haben aber bekannt sind und um das więc so ein bisschen bisschen klammer zu ernten
Was ist das? Das wusste ich schon mal. Ach so, Elder Scrolls Online. Das ist ein Addon für Elder Scrolls Online, ja.
Das ist definitiv ein besseres Online. Jetzt mal ernsthaft, die wollen uns wirklich erzählen, dass allen Ernstes... Moment, Moment.
Ah, fuck, ich hab so Hunger. Die wollen uns allen Ernstes erzählen, dass Animal Crossing New Horizons ein besseres Multiplayer-Spiel ist, als ein MMO.
Jetzt... Ist das wirklich euer Ernst, ja? Ich bin fertig jetzt. War genug für heute.
Okay, also, gucken wir uns quick und wir lassen uns Chebaten vom Level Cap Video ein. Wo sind wir?
Okay, ich lasse mich kurz mal Chebaten von Level Cap, also.
Ja, ich hab gesehen, es gibt einen Trailer zu Path of Exile 2.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung, 15 Sekunden. Battlefield, danach irgendwas anderes. All the rage. Oh. Das hätte ich... Ach so, Moment. Das ist... Ah nee, das ist auch nicht mal einer von DICE. Das hätte ich auch malen können, ja?
Ich hoffe halt, sie machen nicht Features rein, dass sie geile Features drin haben, sondern sie machen Features rein, weil sie gut zum Gameplay passen.
Das ist so die Sachen, wo ich so meine Bedenken hab bei aktueller Spielentwicklung. So nach dem Motto, wir haben eine gute Spielidee, wir bauen darauf aus, auf und bauen Features rein, die dazu passen.
Zum Beispiel, wie man das, sagen wir mal, in Bad Company 2 mit Destruction und so gemacht hat. Oder aber, bei so Games wie Anthem, wo es genau umgedreht war, man hat gesagt, wir bauen ein paar geile Sachen zusammen. Oh fuck, jetzt haben wir ja gar kein Game, was diese geilen Sachen zusammenhält.
Das hab ich so meine Bedenken. Also, es macht wenig Sinn, die geilen Dinge, die einem so einfallen, einzubauen, ohne dass das irgendwie sinnvoll zusammengehalten wird. Also, ich bin mal gespannt.
Ja, 2. Mai würde auch gut passen für einen Reveal. Ganz ehrlich, die ganzen Trailer sind immer so in dem Dreh rausgekommen, jetzt so ungefähr.
Illuminati liegt...
Ja, gut. Datum kommt ungefähr hin. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, sie wollen vielleicht ein bisschen vor Call of Duty, vielleicht wollen sie diesmal, vielleicht machen sie diesmal auch Trick 17 und warten bis Call of Duty rauskommt. Und, äh, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das machen wollen.
Ja, gut. Datum kommt ungefähr hin. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, sie wollen vielleicht ein bisschen vor Call of Duty, vielleicht wollen sie diesmal, vielleicht machen sie diesmal auch Trick 17 und warten bis Call of Duty rauskommt. Und, und Call of Duty wird es richtig verscheißen und dann, bam, kommt Battlefield danach und ist gut. Könnte ja auch sein.
Das entsteht und fällt nur damit, ob Battlefield 6 gut ist oder nicht. Das wird natürlich schwierig, ja. Mal gucken, mal gucken. Also, kommt für PC, PS4, PS5, Xbox One, Xbox... Ist das allen Ernstes die neue Xbox-Abkürzung, ja?
Da sieht man schon wieder, wie verkackt der Name ist. Ich mein, Xbox One kann man ja noch erkennen, aber Xbox Series X, Alter. Und was ist mit Xbox Series S? Die gibt's ja auch, das unterstützt ja auch, also das ist jetzt quasi Xbox Series S und X oder, oder, oder was, oder...
Ai, ai, ai.
Das ist immer so, das halte ich auch immer für so ein Gerücht. Wenn die Leute sagen, oh nein, das geht mit aktueller Konsolen-Hardware nicht, das stimmt einfach in der Regel nicht. Das hängt ganz entscheidend von dem Game ab und wie du Sachen in dem Game implementierst, ob das auf aktueller Konsolen-Hardware läuft oder nicht.
Wenn du ein Game machst, was hauptsächlich auf dem PC unter aktuellen Konsolengenerationen laufen soll und dann, äh, versuchst du es auf der Switch laufen zu lassen, da kommst du einen Crap raus wie bei Witcher 3. Was zwar immer noch Witcher 3 ist, aber halt Witcher 3 Ultralight.
Weil das funktioniert nicht. Wenn du ein Game direkt im Hinblick entwickelst darauf, dass das eben mit einer gewissen Hardware klar kommt und du guckst, dass das ordentlich gemacht ist, dass du nicht zu viele Objekte hast, dass du irgendwelche Sachen halt so baust für die jeweilige Hardware, dann funktioniert das auch.
Weil hier auch ein Leaker sagen wird, meine Leaks stimmen nicht. Das ist natürlich Big Brain.
Das war, hier Leute, war das nicht der Trailer für diesen neuen Spielmodus mit Träger, ähm, äh, Dings, wie heißt das, äh, Flugzeugträger einnehmen oder Carrier, irgendwas, was da nie einer gespielt hat in Battlefield 4? Carrier Assault?
Carrier Assault, ja, was keiner gespielt hat irgendwie. Ken zusammenzockt, klar, guck ich fast jedes Video, ähm, und ich hab da auch schon öfters Comments reingeschrieben.
Ok, das Animal Crossing Video weiß ich nicht, ob ich geguckt hab. Doch, klar, doch, doch, das hab ich geguckt.
Ja, macht das echt gut.
Das ist geil, da hab ich auch letztens, ich spiel ja keinen Warzone mehr, das Game hat mich nie so wahnsinnig gecatched, aber das witzige ist, das hab ich sogar auch schon gesehen, ich weiß nicht, was mit dem Entwickler los ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Mittlerweile glaub ich, es gibt zwei Varianten. Entweder sind die komplett unfähig, oder aber, und ich glaube das ist bei Call of Duty sogar wahrscheinlicher, ist das alles Absicht.
Weil, wenn man nicht mit Inhalten großartig punkten kann, muss man halt mit Aufregung punkten.
Genau, die haben nämlich, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, welche Waffe das ist, wie gesagt, ich hab das schon bestimmt keine und drei Monate oder so nicht mehr gespielt.
Es gibt wohl jetzt irgendwie Akimbo Pistols, die haben einen riesen Magazin, genau, die haben einen riesen Magazin, machen Damage, und das ist quasi die G18 Akimbo von Warzone jetzt. Guckt euch das mal an.
Can't wait, can't wait, alle. Und das war noch nicht mal die optimale Range für das Ding.
Okay, okay, wenn die an einem Balance-Update arbeiten, bedeutet das einfach nur, die haben sich das von Blizzard übrigens abgeguckt. Blizzard ist Meister im Balancing, so zu balancen wie die Warzone balancen.
Also Blizzard macht das seit Jahren schon, und zwar Blizzard Balancing sieht so aus. Irgendeine Klasse ist leicht bis Mittel-OP. So, jetzt gibt's die Variante, man passt das irgendwie sinnvoll an, bufft vielleicht ein paar Counterklassen und alles ist gut.
Aber nein, nein, nein, nein. Die Blizzard-Logik ist, wir passen die Klasse an, plus machen noch alle Spells der Klasse 15% schlechter, sodass sie danach komplett useless ist und keiner mehr spielen will fürs nächste halbe Jahr.
Das ist die Blizzard-Balancing-Taktik. Die machen, normalerweise würde man erwarten, dass Balancing-Änderungen ungefähr, Moment, Huge-Paint-Skills, also normalerweise würde man erwarten, dass Balancing-Änderungen ungefähr, oh, Massive-Craft.
Normalerweise würde man erwarten, dass Balancing-Änderungen irgendwie so aussehen. Wenn hier optimale Balance ist, würdest du halt sagen, manche Helden starten da, manche Helden starten da, okay, dann schießt man vielleicht bei Balancing übers Ziel raus und irgendwie so ungefähr so geht's dann halt weiter.
Also du wirst nie perfekte, du wirst es nie perfekt gebalanced kriegen, ja. Aber Blizzard, Blizzard-Balancing ist die ganze Zeit von useless zu OP, useless zu OP, useless zu OP, das ist Blizzard-Balancing.
Das hier wäre normales Balancing, so wie das zum Beispiel hören sagen, hören sagen, ich spiel Dota 2 nicht, wie das Dota 2 wohl ganz gut hinbekommt, hören sagen, ich weiß es nicht, ich spiel's nicht.
Alter, so, und das ist, das ist, das ist Blizzard, das ist Blizzard-Balancing, was ihr hier seht, ne, also eigentlich, eigentlich voll Lemmets.
XY bitte beschrifft, beschrifft, beschrifft mal Y, Alter, X, exquisite, so, sehr schön.
Massive-Paint-Skills, ja, so würde ich das mit Balancing eigentlich erwarten, das sieht man übrigens bei Blizzard, sowohl bei Overwatch sieht man das, man sieht das bei MMO-Klassen, Nerfs und alles, kriegen das nicht gebacken.
Und ich hab den Eindruck, dass Raven Software sich das Blizzard-Balancing abgeguckt hat.
In dem sie nämlich genau den gleichen Scheiß machen, oh, OP, in Boden nerven und was anderes am besten auch gleichzeitig so krass buffen, dass es OPS-Fuck ist.
Die kriegen, die können das nicht, die kriegen das, die kriegen das nicht gebacken.
Und ich glaube mittlerweile, dass sie das zu einem Feature gemacht haben, dass die das sogar absichtlich in Kauf nehmen, weil ganz im Ernst, was gibt es besseres als nach einem Warzone-Update
erst mal eine Woche Aufregung, eine Woche Analyse-Videos, eine Woche OP-Diskussionen und sonst was.
Das ist doch das Beste für die, was die machen können, um das ganze Ökosystem, das ganze Warzone-Ökosystem am Laufen zu halten.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding gewesen, das ist auch so ein Ding gewesen, wo ich mir so denke, wie kann einem das in Tests nicht auffallen?
Die haben einen neuen Skin reingebracht, wo der Kopf unsichtbar war, du konntest diesen Charakter nicht headshotten.
Und danach kamen sie irgendwie sogar auf die Idee zu klitschen, dass man den Charakter irgendwie komplett unsichtbar machen konnte.
Ich mein, wie kann das sein, dass einem das nicht auffällt beim Testen?
Ich mein, mir ist klar, dass Warzone ein recht komplexes, großes Ding ist.
Dass da kein Team aus 400 Leuten da sitzt und jeden einzelnen Change drei Wochen testet, ist mir auch klar.
Aber solche Dinge könnte man mit Sicherheit auch zumindest zum Teil automatisch testen.
Und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum umso größer und umso komplexer Softwareprojekte werden, umso wichtiger das eigentlich ist,
dass du eine große Anzahl an automatischen Tests hast, die du laufen lassen kannst, um zu gucken, ob so die Basics-Sachen einfach noch gehen.
Man kann es natürlich auch testen, indem man die Spieler spielen lässt und einfach wartet, bis sie sich aufregen.
Tests sind aber nicht Agile. Hey, es gibt ja kaum was Agileres als Tests.
Exzellent.
Oder man macht einen Test-Server wie Overwatch. Genau, das wäre auch eine Variante.
Man möchte es natürlich relativ schnell rauspushen. Die sollen einfach mal ein Test-Wochenende machen.
Guck mal, das wäre relativ easy. Patch kommt Dienstags. War es nicht Dienstags? Immer waren die Warzone-Patchen?
Weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr. Irgendetwas war Patch-Day oder Dienstags. War das Warzone?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander? Ist auch egal.
Im Angenommen, Patch-Day ist Dienstags, da sollten sie einfach einen Test-Server, Beta-Wochenende-Test-Server machen.
Das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich kein allzu großes Problem. Es würden sicherlich genug Leute mitmachen.
Und da könnte man gleich mal ausprobieren, ob das Scheiß funktioniert.
Das wäre jetzt kein großes Ding. Aber warum machen sie es nicht? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung.
Das ist übrigens auch eine typische Blizzard-Sache. Blizzard redet prinzipiell nicht darüber, wenn sie Sachen verkackt haben.
Also sprich, wenn ein Patch schlecht ist, man muss sagen, Jeff von der Overwatch-Team hat es am Anfang relativ gut gemacht.
Also ich war echt begeistert zu Entwicklungszeiten, zu Beta-Zeiten und Anfang zu Release-Zeiten,
wie gut die mit den Leuten kommuniziert haben. Aber irgendwann hat sich Blizzard gedacht,
fuck you, wir reden mit euch gar nicht mehr und veröffentlichen auch kein Content mehr für Overwatch.
Außer vielleicht mal irgendwie einen Map-Teaser pro Jahr.
Und das ist, das ist typische Blizzard-Taktik.
Ich frage mich, was machen denn ihre Community-Manager eigentlich? Außer Twitter-Posts machen.
Ich meine, allein schon die Antwort da drauf ist schon geil, ne?
Achso.
Okay, das ist einfach absolut nichts sagen der Antwort. Absolut nichts sagen der Antwort, ja.
So und so könnte man das Spiel verbessern. Ganz ehrlich, das wäre eher was, wo ich an den ihrer Stelle nicht darauf reagiert hätte.
Oder ich hätte irgendwas geteased oder sonst was, aber das ist einfach so ne, ja, ist uns eigentlich egal.
Übrigens am besten, am besten, Leute, das muss ich euch jetzt erzählen, das ist aber auch schon ne ganze Weile her.
Ich hab ja, ich hab da früher, ich hab da früher ne MMO gespielt hier.
Und das war, gerade im, die waren bekannt dafür, sowohl der englischsprachige Herr, also das war Mystic Entertainment, die waren irgendwann mal EA dann.
Und auch die Deutschen, die das, oder nicht die Deutschen, ich glaub Franzosen waren, dass die das betrieben haben in Europa.
So und die hatten nen Feature, die hatten nen Feature, wo man Verbesserungen einreichen konnte.
Und man hat damals schon gesehen, die haben keinen Bock, das war echt die schlechteste Kommunikation, die ich je gesehen hab von einem Hersteller.
Also die hatten so nen System, da konnte man Verbesserungen einreichen und die hatten keinen Bock, sich selbst damit zu beschäftigen.
Wohlgemerkt, wir reden hier von keinem aktuellen MMO mit Millionen Spieler oder so.
Zumindest der Hersteller selbst hatte keinen Bock, sich das Ganze anzugucken.
Dementsprechend haben die sich, haben die Community Leute ernannt für die jeweiligen Klassen in dem Spiel, die quasi Verbesserungsvorschläge sammeln sollten.
Und ich hab da auch ein paar Sachen eingeschickt, immer mal wieder, weil ich irgendwie damals noch gedacht habe in meinem jugendlichen Leichtsinn, das würde jemand interessieren.
Und die Antworten sahen dann ungefähr so aus.
Also der Typ, also dieser Klassenlead, wo man eigentlich sagen würde, es müsste eigentlich ein Angestellter beim Hersteller sein, aber scheiß drauf.
Dieser Klassenlead hat es quasi gesammelt, die Vorschläge aus der Community und so ein bisschen gefiltert.
Da waren auch echt gute Sachen dabei.
So, und das war so geil, die haben dann einmal im Monat hat der Hersteller auf diese Vorschläge geantwortet.
Und das war jeden Monat so richtig voll in your face.
Die haben einfach die Vorschläge genommen und haben unter 99% haben die geschrieben nein.
In irgendeiner anderen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Die haben sich dann immer, die hatten so drei Standardsätze.
Die haben geschrieben no, this is by design, no design decision oder irgendwas anderes.
No balancing issues.
Die hatten so diese drei Antworten.
Und die haben quasi jeden Monat das, was die Spieler eingeschickt haben.
Und was die Leute sich in ihrer Freizeit hingesetzt haben, aufbereitet haben als quasi Verbesserungsvorschläge Liste.
Wo der Hersteller vorher sogar gesagt hat, sie wollen sowas haben.
Haben die wirklich jeden einzelnen Vorschlag abgelehnt mit einem dieser drei Copy Paste Sachen.
Und es hat mich damals so abgefuckt, dass ich denen mal eine übelste Flame Mail geschrieben hab.
Hab ich natürlich auch keine E-Mail bekommen und ich hab mich damals auch übelst reinsteigern können in sowas.
Ich hab die damals übelst beleidigt von Männern.
Also richtig hängen geblieben.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich war halt damals, wie ich schon öfters gesagt hab, die größten Hater sind die größten Fans.
Es ist einfach so.
Ich war damals richtig geiler Fanboy von dem Game und wollte halt, dass das Spiel geiler wird.
Und die haben das alles nur ignoriert und ich hab die halt voll zugeflamet.
Also sowohl die deutschen Betreiber als auch Mystic Entertainment selbst haben die wahrscheinlich nie gelesen.
Ich hab auch im Forum damals übelst rumgeflammt und da bin ich by the way nicht der Einzige.
Wisst ihr wofür der Overwatch Teamleiter früher bekannt war?
Das war ein ziemlich guter, ich weiß nicht ob es Guildenleiter war, aber hier Overwatch.
Jeff.
Er hier.
Der war früher EverQuest 2, entweder Guilden, wurdest du gebannt?
Nein, wurde ich nicht.
Ich wurde mal gebannt, weil ich Leute beleidigt habe, aber das war ich nicht.
Er war früher Top EverQuest 2 Raider und hat paar richtig heftige Flame Posts verpasst.
Das war früher auch so ein richtig, richtig geiler MMO-Flamer.
Und irgendwie waren viele Leute früher so und die sind jetzt, ich ja auch und irgendwie haben sich alle ein bisschen beruhigt.
Das dauert einfach nur so seine Zeit.
Ich hab die krass geflammt.
Aber es ist ja auch bescheuert.
Warum fragst du deine Community nach Verbesserungsvorschlägen und schreibst dann zu jedem Verbesserungsvorschlag
No. Warte mal, ich versuche euch mal so ein Report zu zeigen.
No Design Decision.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das schreibt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt so was noch gibt.
No Design Decision.
Hier wird sich noch, hier wird...
Ehh, auf Französisch, Alter.
Team Lead Reports, ja.
Das war so fail, ich weiß es interessiert euch nicht, aber ich muss jetzt Cool Story Bro machen.
Ehh, keine Ahnung.
The fuck?
Das, ey, das, okay, das findet man heute nicht mehr.
Design Decision.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das schreibt.
Das findet man heute nicht mehr. Design Decision.
Ich kann es ja mal schreiben.
Das findet man heute nicht mehr.
Naja, zumindest der Hersteller hat zu jedem Punkt immer geschrieben No.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Und, warum ich das alles erzählt habe, daran erinnert mich das irgendwie ein bisschen.
By the way, da sind auch schon wieder alle am Flame.
Ich verfolge das ja so ein bisschen am Twitter, die sagen, Alter, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Verdansk.
Und Zombie Verdansk juckt auch irgendwie keinen und reskinnt Verdansk will auch keiner.
Tja, die wollten eigentlich eine neue Map.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Also ich mein, so interessant vielleicht auch die Warzone Map gestaltet sein mag,
aber im Prinzip haben die ja nur zwei Maps, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne?
Die haben die eine kleinere Map, die mit Cold War gekommen ist, dieses Island.
Und die haben Verdansk, das war's.
Oder?
Ist auch Free to Play, was erwartet man?
Naja, Pupke.
Okay, Pupke muss man kaufen.
Apex ist auch Free to Play.
Und außerdem ist Free to Play ja gar kein Argument.
Man muss sich mal entscheiden, für was jetzt Free to Play eigentlich ein Argument sein soll.
Also ist es entweder, wenn die Leute abgezockt, weil zu viel Geld,
oder muss man sich mit zu wenig Inhalten zufrieden geben, weil zu wenig Geld.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Also gerade Free to Play macht shitload auf Geld für die.
Also kann man nicht sagen, es ist Free to Play, es gibt zu wenig Maps.
Gerade weil es Free to Play ist und die massig Kohle machen, sollten sie ordentlich Content dranbringen.
Und nicht seit über einem Jahr auf dem gleichen Kram rumreiten.
Ich glaube Zombies ist das, was ich am längsten gespielt habe von Cold War.
Also irgendwie vier Stunden oder so.
Mehr, mehr nicht.
Achso doch, die Kampagne habe ich durchgespielt.
Die Kampagne war sogar ganz gut.
Aber ist doch deutlich hinter den Möglichkeiten zurückgeblieben.
Ach, okay.
Habe ich nicht mehr gespielt die letzten zwei Seasons.
... expansion adds a system where players can risk their items to get valuable rewards and trials that raise the difficulty over time.
There's a race to get good stuff, because it will outclass existing items, making them extremely valuable on the in-game economy system.
But the launch hasn't gone smoothly.
A bug with the queue system for logging players in cause the queue to stall and make players wait for over two hours.
The developers quickly release...
Also wenn das schon das Distress des Disastrous ist dann weiß ich auch nicht
Also es ist ja es ist jetzt ja nichts
Gamebreaking es ist halt einfach kacke dass man nicht spielen kann ja aber
Disastrous würde ich jetzt mal ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
Okay das ist fail
Haben die Geld fürs Sponsoring bekommen stellt stellt euch mal vor ein Hersteller und ihr macht aus
Sponsored Stream um 11 ihr loggt euch um 11 ein und das Game ist down ihr wartet eine halbe Stunde das Game ist immer noch down und dann
Easy Money
Das stimmt
Die haben die haben die streamer die haben die streamer in die queue vorgeschoben wieso dafür muss man sich doch nicht entschuldigen das finde
Ich vollkommen vollkommen legitim wer sich da drüber aufregt der hat glaube ich
Nicht nicht mal zwei sekunden versucht reinzusetzen wie das ist so ein spiel zu betreiben
Ja aber nicht nur streamer auch deren freunde
Ja ok da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten je nachdem ob das group content ist oder nicht
Also wenn das group content ist dann verstehe ich
Aber dass man die streamer vorzieht das ist voll logisch
Jaja
Das ist immer so eine geile antwort ja wir will also planen future mal
Dass das zukünftig nicht mehr passieren wird es ist ja nicht so als hätten die das jetzt absichtlich gemacht ja hätten die das absichtlich gemacht
Ja hätten die das absichtlich gemacht dass das so kacke lounge dann könnte man in zukunft quasi vermeiden oder man kann man kann eventuell das
Vorbeugen was man diesmal verkackt hat aber man kann doch nicht sagen ja ja das kommt in zukunft nicht mehr vor das ist einfach
Beruhigungstaktik und es wird immer mal probleme kommen zu problemen kommen und solange das ordentlich gehandelt wird vom hersteller finde ich ist das
auch überhaupt kein problem
Ich finde ich finde das ist wirklich kein ding ich bin auch der meinung dass es hersteller durchaus mal
Verkacken dürfen ja sei es mit sachen die nicht laufen irgendwelchen bugs oder sonstigen dinge wichtig ist wieder mit umgegangen wird ja wenn natürlich
Dann die die blizzard taktik gemacht wird oder die die raven soft taktik wir patchen es nach zwei wochen und sagen in der ganzen zeit nix
Das ist natürlich kacke ja aber wenn man wenn man das ordentlich handelt ja ordentlich mit den leuten die spielen wollen kommuniziert und nicht
unrealistische dinge erzählt so nach dem motto
Bitte versucht mal euren router neu zu starten und guckt ob das logging geht das packt mich nämlich immer ab das ist eine sache die die
Mir richtig auf den sack geht wenn hersteller versuchen oder generell leute dies verkackt haben davon abzulenken dass es an ihnen liegt
So nach dem motto man launched neues add-on oder man hat irgendwie den bug drin und die leute können nicht einloggen die leute backen rum die leute
legen crashen was auch immer
auch immer und wenn die sich dann an den hersteller wenden oder oder im forum posten oder so und wenn dann die hersteller darauf antworten so nach dem
Motto check check doch mal euren router installiert doch mal das game neu
Mach mal einen registry cleaner und sowas das fangt mich immer ab wenn sie genau wissen dass es an ihnen liegt aber
Quasi um zu um zeit zu schinden die leute erst mal irgendwie
Sinnlose fix aktionen machen lässt von denen man genau weiß sie bringen nix
expansions launch without these sorts of problems as for why the game needs a queue system if everyone could just log in all at
Once these servers for the game would become wildly unstable
It just so happens that this time around path of exiles developers had a bug in their queue system typically their launches are very smooth
Ubisoft are shutting down the servers for several of their classic multiplayer games titles like assassins creed 2
Far Cry 2 Splinter Cell conviction
Na gut
Der multiplayer der multiplayer von assassins creed hat mich eh nicht gejuckt
Ghost Recon Future Soldier
Ah, das ist ja schon uralt
Ok
5 Jahre ist aber auch schon ordentlich davor durften sie gar nicht mehr
Vor live
Die eine Angelegenheit ist, dass Spieler, die einen VAC-Band bekommen,
nach dem Konzert in einem offiziellen Tournament,
immer noch von dem Konzert ausgeschlossen sind.
Valve hat auch einen großen Ausgleich in ihrem Spiel verpackt,
der Community-Server genutzt wird.
Der Bug war vor zumindest zwei Jahren da.
Sie haben ihn nach 5 Jahren verpackt.
Sie haben den Ausgleich auf Twitter veröffentlicht.
Bevor wir auf unsere letzte Geschichte der Woche kommen,
danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich hoffe, wir haben alle den größten Storys,
die ihr von uns hören wollt.
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
Oder wir sehen uns am Montag für ein weiteres Video.
MMO Elder Scrolls Online
verlässt reale Geld-Transaktionen für in-Game-Loot-Kräfte.
Die nächste Update des Spiels
wird neue optionalen Sidequests geben,
die euch eine neue Gründung bieten.
Spieler können diese Gründung
in in-Game-Loot-Kräften verpacken.
Die Veränderung wird wahrscheinlich gemacht,
weil Microsofts Prozesse über in-Game-Loot-Kräfte
von Gameplay erheblich werden müssen.
Mit Microsofts Warnung von Bethesda
wird einiges mit Bethesdas Spiels verändern.
Das war's für diese Woche im Spiel.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das ist so hart.
Damit kannst du echt Leute krass trollen.
Kurz jemand abgehen, man klopft.
Also das ist wirklich fies, das Ding.
Sind ja schon viele Streamer übelst mitgetrollt worden.
Ja klar, geht ja auch.
Was meint ihr, warum ich das nie machen werde,
wenn man random Sounds bei mir im Stream abspielen kann?
Selbst selbst geprüfte YouTube-Links nicht.
So, okay, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Doom, Kitchen Appliance,
Kampfansage an Diablo 3,
Passive Exile, das gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall noch an.
Passive Exile 2 werde ich auf jeden Fall spielen.
Warum Logos immer simpler werden, gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Okay, hat ja vorher schon jemand geschrieben.
Sollte ich mal reingucken. Gucken wir jetzt mal rein.
Nee.
Das habe ich noch überhaupt gar nicht mitbekommen.
Was sollen, was wollen sie machen?
Wollen sie sich Rechte an Nintendo-Charakteren für ihre Games sichern oder was?
Okay, Microsoft sollen gemeinsam spielen.
Nintendo und Xbox.
Ja gut, da bräuchte ich keine Switch mehr.
Aber dazu wird es wahrscheinlich nicht kommen.
Okay, ich glaube, das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute.
Na ja.
Es könnte ja auch umgedreht sein, dass auf der Switch einige Microsoft-Spiele kommen werden.
Aber wisst ihr, wovon man definitiv profitieren könnte?
Nur in der Stadt Nintendo Online.
Aber das werden sie nicht machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher so, dass der Game Pass auf die Switch kommt teilweise.
Ja gut, das ist doch in Ordnung.
Das spricht ja nur wirklich gar nichts dagegen.
Grüße an den Friseur, ja, mache ich, wenn ich ihn wieder sehe.
Hörst du für den Sub?
Buxter 512.
Exquisite Subscription.
Ja, das kann doch gut sein, wäre doch auch gar nicht schlecht.
Hat mich nur wie einige Sachen auf der Switch laufen sollen.
Ich meine, so was wie Gears of War ist halt schlecht auf der Switch laufen lassen können, Alter.
Ich stelle mir grad vor, Gears of War auf der Switch.
Streaming, oh nee.
Oh nee, hör mal auf, hör mal auf.
Game Streaming, einfach der Sack schlechter.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich das Einzige, wie du es laufen lassen kannst.
Die haben doch auch Doom portiert, ja, aber wie...
Also wie Witcher 3.
Okay, also warum werden Logos immer simpler?
Also ich, ich sag ja, dass es die größten Kacknoobs verstehen.
Und weil die Leute mit simplen Logos auch simpel zu bedienende und gute Software verbinden.
Und weil die Leute immer low-brainiger werden und mit komplexen Logos nicht zurechtkommen.
Ungefähr einen Monat bin ich auf etwas gestoßen.
Das oversimplified Logo-Meme.
Ja, das ist nichts Neues.
Der, der macht das wieder super dramatisch wahrscheinlich, wie er das vorliest.
Ja, das Video ist schon, ist keine Ahnung, das ist alt.
Bestimmt ein halbes Jahr oder so.
Okay, ist es 2001, dann ist es drei Monate alt.
By the way, dieser Kreis ist nicht das Logo des Browsers, bevor jetzt jemand schreibt.
Das ist auch nicht der Browser, sondern das Mozilla-Logo.
Der Angst kriegt.
Aber zurück zum Thema.
Ich war hooked.
Hooked?
What are you going to do to me?
I sure love being me.
I've joined the oversimplification trend.
Was, was geht gerade ab?
Ja gut, aber Twitter hat es ja schon ganz lange, dieses, dieses, einfach nur noch blaue Vogel.
Ja, auch gut.
Edge, ja.
Irgendwann, nach einer guten Stunde verlorener Lebenszeit, verbracht damit 100 Mal über den gleichen Witz zu lachen, habe ich mich gefragt.
Hm, ist da was dran?
Werden moderne Logos zu simpel, zu clean?
Nee, moderne Logos werden halt zu dem Zeitgeist entsprechend gemacht.
Das kann in zwei, drei Jahren schon wieder ganz anders aussehen.
Wenn Apple jetzt, ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn Apple jetzt auf die Idee kommt, dass alle Logos gefällig so auszusehen haben, machen da eh wieder die meisten mit.
Cleanen Logos gibt es seit einer ganzen Weile.
Und es scheint einfach nicht aufzuhören.
Keine Marke scheint da vorsichtig zu sein.
Keine Marke scheint da vorsicher.
Petco, Pringles, Warner Brothers, jede Fashionbrand der Welt, Intel, die NBA Finals, Google, Microsoft, Airbnb, Spotify, Pinterest, eBay, unser Logo, wobei das definitiv eine gute Entscheidung war, die Liste ist endlos.
Es gibt aber auch noch genug welche mit schlechtem Logo, aber trotzdem.
...dem geilen Schnörres des Mr. P. und seinem coolen Mittelscheitel. Zerstören die Corporate Overlords unsere geliebten Marken. Ist es nicht schädlich?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich wusste gar nicht, dass Pringles ein neues Logo hat. Wusstet ihr das?
Ich dachte, Pringles sieht immer noch so aus.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Pringles überhaupt ein neues Logo hat.
Zerstören die Corporate Overlords unsere geliebten Marken. Ist es nicht schädlich für die Unternehmen, wenn alle gleich aussehen? Eine Exkursion.
Logos sind wichtig.
Ein gutes Logo kann Interesse wecken, eine Firma von Wettbewerbern absetzen, einen Wiedererkennungswert sicherstellen, bestimmte Assoziationen wecken und kommunizieren, um was es bei dem jeweiligen Unternehmen geht.
Ein Logo kommuniziert nicht nur Sachen, es kommuniziert auch häufig. Es ist auf Websites, Verpackungen, Arbeitsuniformen etc.
Deshalb ist es natürlich wichtig, wie ein Logo designt ist. Je einzigartiger die Schrift, je mehr Bilder oder Details, desto mehr...
Ah, jetzt. Sekunde, Sekunde, ich muss das passende Bild zu rausholen. Exzellent.
Jetzt erst mal eine Runde 500 Jahre an den Rotwein.
Ah, yes. Okay, weiter geht's.
... und Infos kann man rüberbringen. Dieses Logo sagt mehr aus als dieses Logo.
Dazu gibt es auch eine interessante Studie aus dem Jahr 2019. Die Influence of Logo Descriptiveness on Brand Equity. Die Studie hat 597 Logos ausgewertet und verglichen.
Zum Beispiel wurden Probanden zufällig in zwei Gruppen aufgeteilt. Beiden Gruppen wurde jeweils die gleiche kurze Beschreibung eines fiktiven Sushi-Restaurants, Logos ausgewertet.
Ist das One Head, oder was?
Oder was soll uns das sagen?
Head.
Ich, ich bin immer noch für Five Head.
Two Head.
Beiden Gruppen wurde jeweils die gleiche kurze Beschreibung eines fiktiven Sushi-Restaurants vorgelegt, aber mit jeweils unterschiedlichen Logos. Der ersten Gruppe wurde ein beschreibendes Logo des Restaurants...
Ich bin der Trigger, dass es hier nur Männer und Frauen gibt auf dem Bild. Was ist da los? Anzeige ist raus.
Der zweiten Gruppe wurde eine weniger beschreibende Version des selben Logos gezeigt. Das Stück Sushi war hier nur ein schwarzer Zylinder. Die erste Gruppe hat das Restaurant als authentischer und sympathischer wahrgenommen als die zweite.
Das ist, by the way, das ist kein Sushi, das ist eine Datenbank. Sind wir uns einig, oder? Das ist das Datenbank-Symbol.
Das war allerdings nur ein Experiment aus der Studie. Die Forscher haben auch finanzielle Informationen von 423 Unternehmen analysiert und mit ihren jeweiligen Logos abgeglichen.
Unternehmen mit beschreibenden Logos hatten tendenziell höhere Umsätze als Unternehmen mit nicht beschreibenden Logos.
Gut, das könnte auch daran liegen, die Leute, die ordentliche Logos machen können, sind erfolgreichere Geschäftsleute. Lachow, vier Monate, danke schön für das Zapp.
27 Logos von Start-ups an rund 2600 Personen getestet. Auch hier schienen beschreibende Logos stärker die Bereitschaft zu erhöhen, das jeweilige Produkt zu kaufen.
Die gesamte Studie legt also nahe, dass beschreibende Logos nicht beschreibenden Logos in vielen Punkten überlegen sind.
Sie machen Marken authentischer und werden positiver wahrgenommen und führen potenziell zu mehr Verkäufen.
Ich brauche auch ein neues Logo. Anstatt Keks mache ich einfach nur noch ein gelbes Viereck.
Aber das ist trotzdem noch nicht das Ende vom Lied. Denn plot twist, die Ergebnisse gelten besonders für kleinere Marken, die Kunden vielleicht noch nicht kennen.
Je bekannter eine Marke, desto schwächer werden diese Effekte.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich geht es sogar ins Negative, wenn die Leute was mit einer Sache so grundlegend verbinden und es seit Jahren verwenden, wenn sich das dann einfach ändert.
Kann sich noch jemand an den Aufschrei erinnern, als der Kinderschokoladen Kevin nicht mehr Kevin war?
Wo sich alle darüber aufgeregt haben, dass Kinderschokolade nun jetzt kann man überhaupt nicht mehr kaufen, weil der Typ anders aussieht.
Auch Vorteile haben zu simplifizieren. Cleaner Minimalismus ist ein massiver, anhaltender Trend.
Und dem Trend zu folgen kann in sich ein Ausdruck von Modernität sein. So formuliert es zum Beispiel auch Intel in Bezug auf ihr neues Logo.
Es sei eine dramatische Simplifizierung der Marke, denn man will eine Modern Brand sein.
Ein eher schmuckloses Logo ist häufig auch zeitloser und kann so einen sehr nachhaltigen Wiedererkennungswert bieten.
Hier wäre unsere Lieblingsfirma Shell ein gutes Beispiel.
Große Firmen bieten oft auch viele verschiedene Produkte und Services an.
Deshalb ergibt es in diesen Fällen manchmal...
Hör ich sonst auch immer, wenn ich Offstream bin.
... auf zu spezifische Details zu verzichten. Der wichtigste Grund für ein simpleres Logo ist allerdings Lesbarkeit.
Ja okay, das klingt logisch.
Heute müssen Logos skalierbar sein, erkennbar als kleine Icons auf winzigen Handybildschirmen.
Je einfacher und simpler das Logo, desto flexibler ist es einsetzbar.
Schnörkelose klare Schriften, simple Formen, all das ist auch ein Produkt...
Es ist aber ein Problem, also nicht mit den Logos.
Das ist eine Entwicklung, die auch generell in allen möglichen Anwendungen der Fall ist.
Wohingegen nur früher bei Anwendungen, vielleicht sagen wir mal sowas wie...
Hab ich Thunderbird drauf?
Also in so Dingern wie Thunderbird, die sind jetzt vielleicht nicht so die allergeilsten, übersichtlichsten, aber haben halt saumäßig viele Funktionen.
Die hatten dann früher solche Menüs hier, Sekunde, sowas da.
Das war ganz normal, total unübersichtlich und sonst wie.
Und heute haben halt jede Anwendung so Menüs.
Und in dem Fall hast du noch das Glück, dass die gleichen Funktionen mehr oder weniger in einem anderen Menü verpackt sind.
Du hast aber auch das Gegenteil, du hast halt neue Anwendungen, die haben einfach nur noch drei Buttons,
können auch nur noch das, was auf den drei Button steht und sonst nichts mehr.
Also du hast auch viele Anwendungen, die einfach komplett versimplifiziert sind.
Moin Wettwitz, zwölf Monate!
Das ist ja der erste Hyper-Subscription-Monat.
Für zwölf Monate Subscription, Massive-Subs hier.
Sind die Overlords zu weit gegangen oder macht das schon alles Sinn?
Wenn man als Marke so wirkt wie alle anderen, ist das jedenfalls immer schlecht.
Es gibt sogar einen Begriff für die allgegenwärtige Sun-Serie-Fond, weniger ist mehr, wir sind alle gleich, Designphilosophie.
Blending.
Von to blend in, sich optisch anzugleichen, einzufügen und zu vermischen.
Auch über die Logos hinaus häuft sich in letzter Zeit Kritik an den immer gleichen seelenlosen visuellen Elementen großer Unternehmen.
Dazu empfehlen wir dieses Video vom englischsprachigen YouTuber Solar Sans.
Aha.
Wir formen, ob halbironisch oder nicht, emotionale Bindungen zu Logos.
Diese Bindung ist wertvoll für Firmen und es ist faszinierend, sich bei einem Logo einer großen Firma zu überlegen, wie lange und wie viel wohl darüber nachgedacht wurde.
Viel. Mit Sicherheit viel.
Im Fall von Insta ist mein Logo z.B. mindestens zwei bis drei Minuten.
Trends provozieren Gegentrends. Nostalgie zu den 80ern und 90ern ist allgegenwärtig.
Es kann übrigens auch nach hinten losgehen, ne?
Also Snapchat haben sie ja komplett redesigned und die Snapchat-Leute, die waren außer sich davon, dass die App jetzt nicht mehr benutzt wird.
Filmen und Serien. Langsam findet sich diese Nostalgie auch in Logos wieder.
Diese Logos mögen auch simpel sein, aber nicht clean.
Das neue Firefox-Logo gefällt uns persönlich übrigens eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich mag das letzte, das von 2017, gefällt mir am besten.
Das war eine ganz gute Mischung aus clean und klassischem Firefox.
Habt ihr das neue, der Auer-Video gesehen?
Nö.
Warum ist das erste, was man findet in der Suche der Bauer-Girlfriend-Freundin?
Na gut, die Leute interessieren ja klar. Ich meine, bei seiner Freundin verstehe ich sogar, dass die Leute danach suchen.
Nachdem er das ja auch mal in einem Video thematisiert hat.
Die wollen einfach wissen, was da los ist.
So, ähm...
Unerwartete Ergebnisse. Moment, haben wir nicht letzte Woche sowas, nicht genau das Gleiche geguckt?
Dabei gibt es keine Setup-Geschichte.
Ah, exellent. Guck mal hier.
Moment, Moment, die Werbung muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Moment, ich muss mich mal kurz inspirieren lassen von der Werbung.
Ich hab mit Herzen besprochen, ich mach auch mal, ich versuche auch mal so eine Werbung in dem Stil zu machen.
Und ähm...
Ich hole mir etwas Inspiration.
Vorab, also jetzt im geköpften Zustand, dass wir sicher sein können, dass das die Ausgangssituation ist.
Und ja, ich würd sagen, wir legen auch direkt los.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert von unserem Langzeitpartner Hetzner mit den Hosting-Produkten und Infrastruktur für Privat- und Geschäftskunden.
Und das seit 1997.
Okay, das werd ich auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht so machen.
Jetzt hat ja jeder seinen eigenen Style für.
Data senden in Deutschland und Finnland eine eigene Server- und Rec-Produktion und kann damit auch flexible Server zur Verfügung stellen.
Über die Serverbörse könnt ihr innerhalb von wenigen...
Also, ja, ich weiß schon, das würde ich in der Form wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Ich werd erzählen, dass ich das auch schon eine ganze Weile verwende.
Dass da unter anderem auch einige Projekte von mir drauf laufen und dann zeig ich ein bisschen auch sowas.
Das ist ja letztendlich das Stock-Footage, was alle kriegen.
...euren eigenen dedicated root-Server konfigurieren und mieten.
Dabei gibt es keine Setup-Gebühr oder Mindestvertraglaufzeit und die Server sind sofort verfügbar.
Unlimited-Traffic- und Gigabit-Anbindung seien dabei genauso erwähnt wie die Tatsache, dass Hetzner auf den ökologischen Einsatz der Hardware großen Wert legt und versucht...
Okay, das haben sie bei mir gar nicht angesprochen, dass ich das sagen soll.
...gebrauchte Hardware möglichst weiter zu verwenden. Mehr findet ihr im Link in der Beschreibung.
Das war jetzt unser Ausgangszuschlag.
Ah, okay, der hat einen Special-Link. Okay, so an krieg ich dann wahrscheinlich auch, denk ich mal.
Die müssen das ja tracken können, ob sich das lohnt, wenn man das anklickt.
Ach, das war nicht für Hetzner Cloud, das war für die Serverbörse. Ah, verstehe. Nee, dafür hab ich...
...ich mach Hetzner Cloud sehr laut.
...gebrauchte Hardware möglichst weiter zu verwenden. Mehr findet ihr im Link in der Beschreibung.
Okay, aber das ist doch das gleiche Video im Prinzip wie letzte Woche, oder?
Nur eine andere CPU, oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander? Genau.
Das haben wir doch vor zwei Wochen geguckt, wo ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied?
Das ist doch gar die gleiche CPU? Andere Kühlung? Hat er das letzte Mal noch den Heatspreader dazwischen gemacht?
Der hat das doch das letzte Mal auch direkt drauf geklebt, oder?
Okay, okay, gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal.
Das wird auf jeden Fall wieder richtig, richtig Paynes-Champ zu hören, wenn CPUs knacken.
So tief im Sockel drin saß und eben nicht hoch genug, dass der Kühler oft dann auf den Ecken auflag und gar nicht mehr in der Mitte auf dem Chip.
Da haben wir jetzt unsere CPU. Ich hab gerade eben den Deckel abgenommen, so ist es unten drunter der Zustand mit Flüssigmetall.
Man kann sehen, die Menge war so ziemlich ideal.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich das verletzte, aber auch.
Normal an der Ecke rausgedrückt, aber ansonsten nicht zu viel.
Ich sag euch, Leute, ich hab mir so in die Hose gemacht, als ich meinen CPU geköpft hab.
Er hat sowas ja schon tausendmal gemacht, aber mein 8700k war die erste CPU, die ich damals geköpft hab.
Ich hab echt schon geschwitzt, als die CPU geknackst hat.
Jetzt mach ich das erstmal kurz sauber.
Wir wissen ja aus dem letzten Video, dass die Platine circa 1,2 Millimeter dick ist.
Und jetzt hab ich den Teil gemessen, wo diese kleinen Kondensatoren drauf sind.
Da sehen wir, wir haben eine Dicke von circa 1,55 Millimetern, das bedeutet, wenn wir die jetzt wieder hier rausnehmen, dann wissen wir, dass diese Teile circa 0,3 Millimeter hoch sind.
Und der Chip, den haben wir ja schon gemessen im letzten Video, circa 0,6 Millimeter.
Das bedeutet, wir haben auf jeden Fall nicht viel Platz, aber wir haben genug Platz, um dann letztendlich noch was oben drüber zu kleben, um die abzudecken.
Meine Oma hätte jetzt gesagt, sitzt, bast, wackelt und hat Luft.
Decken wie das hier, dass da kein Kurzschluss entsteht, weil wenn wir da jetzt einfach den Kühler drauf montieren würden und das irgendwie Kontakt hat, dann hätten wir ein Problem.
Aber es ist zum Glück niedrig genug, dass wir Direc-Dy machen können, also es wird nicht mit dem Kühler kollidieren, weil der Chip 0,6 Millimeter hoch ist und das Zeug so 0,35 circa.
Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich auch in meinem wöchentlichen Update-Blog gesehen, dass wir diese Schablonen hier lasergeschnitten haben aus 0,5 Millimeter dicker Folie und das werden wir verwenden, um quasi einen Schutz für die CPU zu realisieren.
In der Vergangenheit war es ja meistens so, dass wir solche Direc-Dy-Frames hier verwendet haben, wie hier zum Beispiel bei einem 9900K.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Ja, da war das natürlich deutlich einfacher, weil 9900K keine Komponenten außen rum hat.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es extra Metallrahmen gibt für direkte Kühlung auf der CPU.
Der war sogar ausgelegt für den 10900K, aber da ist auch das gleiche Spiel, dass wir keine Komponenten im Weg haben.
Ja, okay, Chet ist wieder Massive Brain und weiß das alles.
Jetzt haben wir aber den Vorteil, dass die Platine dicker geworden ist, das heißt, wir sollten mehr Stabilität haben, der Chip ist größer, was uns auch mehr Stabilität gibt und dementsprechend, wenn wir das Teil hier drauf legen und erhöhen...
Habt ihr alle schon, Chet, Pause, habt ihr alle schon mal ein Video von gestern geguckt?
Und dem hier...
Bisschen Werbung machen.
Sollte ja ungefähr 0,1mm Unterschied haben, dann sollten wir alles, was die Platine sich durchbiegt, damit auffangen können, dass die sich nicht zusteigt.
Natürlich, bin ich ja froh.
Letztendlich haben wir ja unten die Pins und es war in der Vergangenheit ein Problem, gerade in den Ecken, also gerade hier so diese untere Ecke und diese Ecke hier, das sind so die Bereiche für den Arbeitsspeicher.
Wenn da irgendwas nicht perfekten Kontakt hat, dann kann es sein, dass Arbeitsspeicherriegel nicht richtig erkannt werden.
Das wollen wir auf jeden Fall vermeiden.
Und wenn wir dann den Chip nehmen, haben das hier oben drauf, dann drückt...
Der braucht schon Arbeitsspeicher.
Dann sollte das eigentlich relativ gut funktionieren.
Ich hab alles im CPU-Cache, ich brauch eigentlich gar keinen RAM.
Die Folie hat eine Dicke von tatsächlich 0,5mm.
Aber im Bereich, wo die Folie geschnitten wird, da schmilzt sie so ein bisschen auf durch den Laserschneider.
Was meint ihr, warum ich C++ programmieren lerne gerade?
Dass ich alles in CPU-Cache kriege und keinen RAM mehr brauche.
Boot to cache, mach ich dann.
Haben wir hier ein bisschen zu viel, das bedeutet wir müssen die Folie, auch wenn sie so dünn ist, erstmal so minimal abschleifen,
dass die überall 0,5mm hat, weil so wäre es zu hoch.
Abschleifen!
Und dann würde der Kühler nicht im Zentrum richtig aufliegen.
Das sieht doch jetzt so schon mal ziemlich gut aus.
Exquisite sieht das aus.
Passt perfekt oben drauf.
Jetzt werde ich das mit Kaptonband in den Sockel kleben.
Und damit schützen wir eben die Komponenten hier drunter und halten die CPU auch gleichzeitig im Sockel fest.
Sieht wirklich super aus, also 1,72mm, gemessen Platine oben mit dem Kunststoffteil oben drauf.
Und dann gemessen Chiphöhe von 1,775mm.
Also 0,05mm Unterschied zwischen dem Plastikteil und dem Chip.
Quasi perfekt.
Sieht ganz annehmbar aus, würde ich sagen.
Klar, ist hier unten so ein bisschen eingeknickt.
Das ist aber vor allem, weil hier hinten...
Ich hätte so Klebeband gar nicht da.
Na, wenn es heraus steht, dann lässt sich das hier unten nicht perfekt anlegen.
Wichtig ist nur, dass es hier oben keine Falte drin hat.
Dass es hier nicht irgendwie geknickt ist oder sowas.
Aber das sieht alles sehr, sehr, sehr gut aus.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ja, dann mal rauf mit dem Flüssigmetall.
Alles klar.
Kontaktor ist drauf.
Sowohl auf der CPU als...
Wer nutzt denn auch Intel, der jemand, der aktuell sich CPUs kaufen können möchte?
Ryzens zu bekommen für einen ordentlichen Preis ist ja zurzeit etwas schwieriger.
Auch auf dem Corsair-Block unten.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Durch den fehlenden Heatspreader sitzt der Kühler jetzt natürlich ein bisschen tiefer.
Das heißt, wir müssen das Mounting ein bisschen anpassen.
Deswegen oben noch eine Unterlagscheibe drauf.
Ansonsten hätten wir zu wenig Anpressdruck.
Okay.
Ich werde jetzt erst mal das Wasser nicht anschließen.
Wir schauen uns einfach mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Ob die CPU erkannt wird oder nicht.
Ja.
Bester RAM.
Bester RAM habe ich auch am Start.
Und wisst ihr, was das Witzige ist?
Ich habe ein Fenster im Rechner,
dass ich mir meinen geilen RGB-RAM angucken kann.
Und meine tolle...
Ich habe sogar Case...
Ich habe sogar Modding für meinen Noctua-Lüfter damals gekauft.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich habe sogar Noctua Black...
Wie heißen diese Dinger?
Ähm...
Wie heißt dieses Noctua RGB...
Dieses Noctua...
Chromax.
Chromax gekauft für meinen Lüfter.
Ja.
So.
Und...
Jetzt habe ich mir gerade letztens gedacht,
als ich so runtergeguckt habe,
ich habe noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit,
überhaupt in meinen Rechner reinzugucken,
weil ich einfach schon seit zwei Jahren was vorm Fenster stehen habe vom Gehäuse.
Also ich habe den gemordeten Lüfter RGB-RAM.
Sieht an sich eigentlich richtig nice aus in dem Rechner.
Aber ich habe seit zwei Jahren einfach was vorm Gehäusefenster drinstehen,
da ich nichts sehe.
Hat sich richtig gelohnt, Chat.
Oder was mein ihr?
Das alles dafür extra Geld auszugeben.
Okay.
Richtig 3-Head.
Hm.
Okay, das Board startet aber kein Debug-Code.
Wozu Debug-Code, wenn es einfach geht?
Das ist nicht so gut.
Also zumindest mal laut LED auf dem Board.
CPU-Erkennungsfehler.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Okay, also was mir gerade mal aufgefallen ist zumindest,
ist, dass der Montagerahmen hier auf den Kondensatoren so ein bisschen aufliegt
und auch gar nicht viel weiter hier runter kann.
Auch hier ist die Gefahr, dass es auf den Kondensatoren aufliegt.
Ach, die Dinger sind stabil.
Da gibt es keinen Kurzschluss dadurch oder so.
Aber wahrscheinlich haben wir deswegen einfach nicht genug Anpressdruck.
Also muss ich vielleicht doch den CPU-Kühler wechseln.
Einfach die Kondensatoren ein bisschen plattdrücken.
Easy, kein Problem, halten die aus.
Was natürlich doof wäre bezüglich unserer Testergebnisse.
Neuer Tag, neues Glück.
Ich habe mir noch einen EK-Block geholt, den ich noch umliegen hatte.
Habe schon die Montage draufgepackt, also Backplate gewechselt und die Pins hier.
Jetzt mal rein, von den Außenmaßen her sollte das eigentlich passen.
Von dem, was ich jetzt kurz gesehen habe.
Das Einzige, was natürlich sein könnte, ist, dass die Teile hier zu hoch sind
und hier der Kühler aufliegt.
Das werde ich jetzt aber eben testen.
Schnell montieren.
Hoffentlich passt das.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Man sieht schon, dass der Kühler deutlich kleiner ist.
Also der kollidiert zumindest mal hier und hier
und auch da hinten nicht mehr mit den Kondensatoren.
Dann checken wir mal.
Nice.
Es läuft.
Ich bin mega happy.
Sehr, sehr cool.
Und es sieht sogar relativ gut aus.
Die Wärme ist aber ziemlich genauso wie letztes Mal, oder?
Es ist doch gar kein großer Unterschied.
War das letzte Mal nicht auch irgendwie 65?
Kein Problem.
Gebootet ohne jegliche Probleme.
3600 C17, also eine normale Konfiguration würde ich mal sagen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen kühler bleibt,
aber ob das so einen großen Unterschied macht,
ob Heatspreader dazwischen oder nicht.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich kenne mich damit nicht gut genug aus,
aber ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen,
so das werden jetzt auch keine Welten sein.
Jetzt machen wir gleich mal einen Cinebench
und schauen, ob der Kontakt so passt.
Kontakt sieht gut aus.
Temperaturen sehen sehr, sehr gut aus.
Wow.
Okay, die bleiben tatsächlich auch unter Last.
Fast genauso kühl.
Noch mal besser als geköpft.
Aber das muss natürlich dann der Prime95-Test
erstmal wieder zeigen nach Aufwärmphase und so weiter.
Da kann man sich jetzt schnell ein falsches Bild holen.
Werden wir dann alles nochmal richtig testen.
Plus ich muss natürlich den Originaltest
mit dem Heatspreader drauf.
Also geköpft nochmal wiederholen mit dem EK-Kühler,
sonst haben wir gar keinen vernünftigen Vergleichswert.
Erster Test sieht auch schon mal sehr vielversprechend aus.
Ich habe jetzt gerade die Testergebnisse ausgewertet
von der Messung mit Direct Dye
versus eben nur geköpft mit dem EK-Kühler.
Glücklicherweise, wenn wir uns die zwei Linien ankommen
erstmal von dem EK-Kühler und dem XC7,
sehen wir, dass die beinahe identisch sind
bzw. die liegen so innerhalb von einem Grad Celsius.
Man kann also quasi sagen...
Okay, Stock ist natürlich schon mal.
Okay.
Direct Dye...
Okay, und das sind...
Äh...
Moment.
Das ist wärmer?
Das ist wärmer mit Direct
als mit Heatspreader dazwischen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Identisch, wenn man die Messtoleranzen berücksichtigt
in so einem Fall.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal noch den Direct Dye-Fall anschauen,
dann sehen wir, die Temperatur liegt sogar darüber.
Der EK-Kühler war bei mir
zumindest mal, wenn wir diese
Scheibe hier verwenden, diese Schablone,
dann war bei mir Direct Dye tatsächlich
schlechter als mal geköpft.
Das kann verschiedene Ursachen haben.
Gegebenenfalls zu wenig Anpressdruck,
weil das Teil vielleicht doch irgendwie im Weg ist.
Oder natürlich auch, weil der Dye relativ groß ist
und man dann auch bedenken muss,
dass so ein CPU-Kühler dafür gemacht ist,
dass die Hitze relativ zentral kommt
und auch von einem Heatspreader verteilt wird.
Der Bronco, da gehe ich mal von aus,
weil Intel das abgewegt hat.
Zwischen, Moment, also hier,
Intel hat garantiert das abgewegt.
Wie viele Leute gibt es überhaupt
potenziell, die sich sowas kaufen würden?
Und wie hoch ist
der Aufwand,
quasi zwei Sachen herzustellen?
Muss das ja auch sicherlich
dann besser verpacken und irgendwie was anders machen.
Und die nächste Frage ist,
wie viel gehen dadurch kaputt?
Also ich denke schon, dass Intel
sich da Gedanken darüber gemacht hat,
aber wir sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, das lohnt sich nicht.
Und jetzt denke ich mir,
probieren wir mal,
ob das auch funktioniert,
wenn wir die Schablone einfach mal komplett weglassen.
Und da sind die CPU
auch schon wieder im Sockel.
Ihr seht, diesmal fehlt die Schablone oben drauf.
Was ist das links oben für eine Grafika?
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist natürlich um die Komponenten,
die hier drauf sind, also hier oben die kleinen SMDs,
um die kleinen SMDs zu schützen,
dass die nicht in Kontakt mit dem Kühler kommen können
und natürlich um das Ganze vor Flüssigmetall zu schützen.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich auch wie so ein Direct Die Frame,
weil wir halten die CPU dadurch im Sockel
und wenn wir den Kühler wieder demontieren wollen,
dann klebt die CPU nicht direkt am Kühler dran.
Funktioniert natürlich hauptsächlich,
weil das jetzt relativ kurzfristig ist.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, wenn es eine Weile ist
und wenn es auch warm wird und alles,
dann löst sich ja dann auch das Klebeband vom Mainboard.
Ja, dran hängt oder zwei.
Dann würde ich mich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass das flüssigen Metall nicht stärker haftet
am Kühler als das Klebeband hier unten.
Also das ist natürlich dann möglich,
dass es nach ein, zwei Jahren ganz anders aussieht.
Und damit ist der CPU-Kühler auch schon montiert.
Wenn ihr das Ganze zu Hause nachmachen solltet...
Man muss ja mal schon eins sagen, ne?
Also Wasserkühlung sieht mittlerweile echt futuristisch aus.
In jedem Fall wichtig, ohne Frame
die Schrauben immer in ganz kleinen Schritten
und immer überkreuzt anzuziehen,
dass der CPU-Kühler auf keinen Fall verkippt.
Beziehungsweise mit dem größeren Teil bei dieser CPU
ist es nicht mehr so ein Risiko wie früher
mit den kleinen Chips, dass es irgendwie verkippt
und dadurch irgendwie der Chip bricht.
Aber es besteht weiterhin also vorsichtig,
immer Schrauben überkreuzt, langsam in Schritten anziehen.
Booted?
Die gute Nachricht ist schon mal, dass es funktioniert.
Also das Cinebench läuft,
Temperaturen sehen jetzt auch nicht besonders schlecht aus.
Aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich besser.
Mal gucken.
Es ist schon hart, wie schnell der Kram mittlerweile rendert.
Ich habe die Testergebnisse jetzt ausgewertet,
aber auch da keine Verbesserung, keine signifikante Änderung
zwischen normal Direct Die oder Direct Die mit dem Rahmen.
Direct Die ohne Rahmen hat auch funktioniert, was interessant ist.
Das hat man ja schon vermutet, weil die Platine dicker ist
und auch der Die größer ist.
Dadurch verbiegt sich die Platine nicht so.
Also ich hatte keinerlei Probleme mit dem Rahmen oder sonst was.
Also auf jeden Fall cool.
Also falls ihr einfach mal spontan Direct Die probieren wollt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
dass es zumindest ein paar Grad kühler ist.
Wenn ihr die Platine geköpft habt,
dann ist es diesmal ein bisschen einfacher,
weil man nicht unbedingt so einen Rahmen braucht.
Das bedeutet, wir werden wahrscheinlich auch für diese Generation
gar keinen Rahmen anbieten.
Vor allem unter dem Aspekt, dass, und da seht ihr jetzt hier,
ich keine signifikante Temperaturänderung feststellen konnte.
Inzwischen, egal welche Direct Die Variante wir gemacht haben,
normal Köpfen, Heatsplatter drauf und dann CPU-Kühler montieren
war bei mir besser.
Und man muss natürlich auch bedenken,
wenn ich den Heatsplatter normal montiere,
dann packe ich hier konventionelle Wärmeleitpaste drauf,
also Kryonaut Xtreme in dem Fall.
Ja, zufälligerweise natürlich die welche sonst.
Wenn ich da jetzt nochmal Kontaktonaut obendrauf packen würde.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich eine eigene Wärmeleitpaste mitdesignt hätte,
ich würde da auch permanent sehr laut für machen.
Warum nicht?
Dann wäre die Temperatur vielleicht nochmal so ein halbes Grad bis ein Grad besser vielleicht.
Ja, das muss man auch noch bedenken,
weil bei Direct Die haben wir ja nur Flüssigmetall im Spiel
und keine konventionelle Wärmeleitpaste.
Das muss man bei den Ergebnissen auch noch bedenken.
Also zusammengefasst würde ich sagen,
Direct Die bei dieser Generation erst mal,
zumindest mal was ich jetzt sehen kann,
nicht empfehlenswert köpfen.
Hat aus welchen Gründen auch immer immer noch
einen großen Temperaturvorteil gebracht.
Ja, wundert mich jetzt zwar ein bisschen,
aber auf der anderen Seite ist mir das auch ziemlich wurscht,
ob das jetzt zwei Grad kühler oder wärmer ist.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich,
gerade wie ich gesehen habe,
wie sehr du da drücken musst, wie kompliziert das ist,
die aktuellen Intel CPUs zu köpfen,
würde ich das wahrscheinlich diesmal nicht machen.
Mit meinem 8700K habe ich es gemacht,
da ging es ja noch ein bisschen
einfacher als jetzt.
Exzellent.
So Chet,
also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an hier?
Doom auf der Küchenappliance?
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
MW2? What the fuck?
MW2 Video auf? Sonst noch Kampfansage?
Und hier, das muss ich mir angucken.
Pass auf was die zu Pass auf Exzellent 2 sagen.
Pass auf Exzellent 2,
sollte das nicht eigentlich schon Ende 2020
mal ursprünglich rauskommen?
Weil der ursprüngliche Trailer
ist ja auch schon wieder zwei Jahre alt.
Wir können auf Battlefield 3 gucken,
eine Runde. Gibt es auch wieder Neues?
Easter Eggs?
Ne, juckt mich jetzt nicht. Kein GameStar Video.
Ihr schreibt alle Bot-Kommentare,
Meiko.
Wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Lockpicking Lawyer.
Den Kerl gucke ich auch immer gern,
weil man dem alles so mega easy aussieht,
wenn es knackt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus
wie eine Docking Station für ein IBM Notebook.
Lockchamp.
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich das sehe,
ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass Amazon
Basics mittlerweile total viele Produkte
im Angebot hat, die erstaunlich
ähnlich sind zu schon bestehenden Produkten,
wo man fast vermuten könnte,
Amazon hat sich da
ein wenig inspirieren lassen
von Produkten, die es schon vorher gab,
um sie jetzt als Amazon Basics
neu rauszubringen.
Aber sowas würde Amazon
selbstverständlich nie machen, Chet.
Da sind wir uns ja einig.
Das ist sicherlich Zufall.
Okay, wir wissen jetzt ja alle schon,
was passiert.
Der wackelt mit seinem Tool zweimal
und es ist offen.
Pulschamp.
Pulsierungschamp.
Der Champ ist doch illegal.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Band emote.
Toz emote.
Excellent.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir
auch, wie man eine Docking Station
knacken kann, alles klar?
Okay, also was, was, was,
was gucken wir uns jetzt an, Leute?
Nee, wir gucken uns jetzt das Pass of Exile Video an.
Da bin ich nämlich echt mal gespannt drauf,
was es da Neues gibt.
Ihr wisst, ich bin Pass of Exile Fan.
Auch wenn ich die letzten zwei Seasons nicht mal
gespielt habe, ist für mich so das beste Action
RPG, was es aktuell so gibt.
Dazu kommt auch noch, dass es
Free to Play ist und sogar ein
recht faires Modell hat, wobei man halt sagen muss,
wenn man Pass of Exile wirklich,
also, wenn man das wirklich
in Kreisel kreiten
will, man
braucht schon ein paar Stashtaps und so was.
Aber es ist nicht un-
übertrieben, also es ist nicht, wie soll
man sagen, nicht unethisch teuer, ja?
Also es ist durchaus
mit wenig Geld zu spielen.
Wisst ihr, was mich das erinnert?
Also ich mein, diese, diese
ähnlichen Mops gibt's ja schon.
Aber von der Optik erinnert mich das ein bisschen an
Titan, nee, ist das Titan Quest?
Ja,
Titan Quests, Titan Quests.
Dieses griechische
Hack and Slay, Slash
Ding.
Livecam von der Katz.
Ja, die bewegt sich nur grad nicht.
Was, was, wie hieß der?
Penetration King?
Moment, Moment, wie hieß der
Mob Boss? Ach nee.
Wie zum Teufel
komme ich auf Penetration King,
Alter?
Kacipatz, Alter.
Was man manchmal für'n Scheiß liest, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, es ist
ehrlich gesagt, ehrlich gesagt, das ist
umgedreht. Diablo
ist mittlerweile
Pass of Exile-Konkurrenten
nicht umgedreht. Also Pass of Exile
ist das Ding, wo du rankommen musst.
Kommen, das haben auch ihre Finger mit drin.
Ich hab auch schon wieder, ich hab auch schon
wieder viel zu viel
Geld in dem Spiel ausgegeben.
Für irgendwelche Skins
und, und, ähm, wie heißt das?
Diese, diese Basis.
Diese, diese, äh, wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Diese Wohnung.
Wie ist das denn nochmal? Äh.
Da wo man im Endgame im Prinz- Hideouts!
Genau, Hideouts, so rum, so, genau.
Ich bin grad nicht drauf gekommen.
Äh, ist Pass of Exile 2 dann auch gratis?
Äh, ziemlich sicher. Ich geh
davon aus, dass Pass of Exile 2
ein Update wird, wie jedes andere Update
auch für Pass of Exile,
das Pass of Exile 2, dass Pass of Exile
dann einfach zu irgendeinem Punkt zu Pass of Exile
2 wird, weil sie haben ja auch schon
gesagt, dass man sich aussuchen
kann, welche Kampagne man spielen will.
Das Endgame bleibt ja eh das gleiche.
Es gibt ein paar Mechanikänderungen und man
kann sich dann aussuchen, welche Kampagne man spielen will,
die von Pass of Exile oder die von Pass of Exile 2.
Also es wird das gleiche Game werden.
Es gibt nicht Pass of Exile 1 und Pass of Exile 2
parallel. Würd mich
zumindest sehr wundern, wenn es anders sein sollte.
Und ich glaube, das wird auch schon so
angedeutet.
Die Story ist
mega scheiße.
Also eins, also ihr wisst,
ich mag das Spiel, ja, ich habe
selbst 100 Stunden rumgegrindet.
Aber die Story ist wirklich
massive Monarch-S, Alter.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute
wissen doch nicht mal, dass das Spiel überhaupt eine Story
hat.
Aber das ist wirklich richtig
Monarch-S.
Das ist tatsächlich eine sinnvolle Baustelle für Pass of Exile 2, denn bei allem mechanischen Tiefgang kam es in Sachen Kampfgefühl gerade im frühen Spiel oft nicht an Diablo 3 heran.
Um das zu verbessern, soll jeder Waffentyp jetzt unschiebliche und einzigartige Mechaniken haben, sodass sich alle Waffen...
Ja gut, die müssen das natürlich, die müssen das so machen, das ist schon ganz klar.
Die meisten Leute, die das spielen,
die werden das nicht bis zum Endgame durchhalten.
Wobei das eine wirklich gute Kurve hat
von Story zu Endgame, ja.
Kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren,
das finde ich ist eine der weichesten Sachen,
die ich kenne in Games, wie die das gemacht haben.
Aber es gibt halt Leute,
die werden nach wie vor einfach reingehen,
die sie so einen Charakter spielen, bis die Story
durch ist und dann fertig. Und dafür brauchen die halt
zwei Monate.
Zwei Waffen wurden dabei im Gameplay
als Beispiel vorgestellt.
Zum einen die neue Speerklasse.
Speere sind vielseitige Waffen, die sowohl
im Nahkampf eingesetzt werden, als auch ein bisschen
Abstand zum Feind schaffen können.
Jeder Speer verfügt dabei über
mindestens eine Mobility-Fähigkeit,
zum Beispiel Engage oder Disengage.
Diese Fähigkeiten ermöglichen und
ermutigen uns, im Kampf mobil zu bleiben.
Die andere vorgestellte Waffenklasse
ist die Armbrust. Hier ist die Besonderheit,
dass sie unterschiedliche Angriffskills
direkt eingebaut haben.
Beeinflussen können wir diese Fähigkeiten,
indem wir über Gems entscheiden, welche Art
von Bolzen unsere Armbrust ist.
Zum Beispiel können wir unsere Feinde mit
einem Permafrostbolzen einfrieren und
danach durchbohren.
Neben kleineren Gegnern werden wir in jedem Gebiet
in Path of Exile 2 Minibossen begegnen,
die individuelle Mechaniken
einsetzen und interessante Kämpfe bieten sollen.
Auch die Umgebung ist dieses Mal
elementarer Bestandteil des Kampfes.
Manche Gegner können die Umgebung
gegen uns verwenden, dabei basiert
aber alles auf einer klaren Logik.
So können Felsen nur dann von der Decke regnen,
wenn an der Stelle auch eine Decke vorhanden ist.
Und woher weiß man, ob das eine Decke ist?
Neben dem, was im Video besonders hervorgehoben wurde,
gibt es aber noch einen ganzen Haufen weitere
Änderungen. Unter anderem wurden unsere
Charakteroptionen deutlich erweitert.
Für das neue Spiel wurden 90...
Noch mehr? Noch mehr?
Ey, ich mein Path of Exile ist ja wohl mal
das Game mit den Abstand
größten Charakter
Skilloptionen aller Zeiten
da.
Neue Ascendancy Klassen entwickelt.
Okay.
Ascendancy Klassen sind die
Spezialisierungen bzw. Subklassen,
die wir unterhalb der sieben
zugrunde liegenden Charakterklassen wählen.
Neben den neuen Klassen
und den bereits erwähnten neuen Waffentypen,
von denen es wahrscheinlich mehr geben wird,
als die zwei, die jetzt im Gameplay präsentiert wurden,
werden außerdem zahlreiche neue
Fähigkeiten ins Spiel implementiert.
Eine dieser neuen Fähigkeiten...
Ey, ich mein, ich mein, ernsthaft,
das Game ist so über...
Das hat so viel Kram drinne, du
blickst da nicht durch. Also
sag mal, allein schon der
Skillbaum an sich ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Aber das in Kombination
mit Gems
und
also mit den eigentlichen
Skills, mit Gem Levels, mit
abgecreateden Gems, mit Wahl Gems,
mit 50
verschiedenen Endgame Mechanics, was du da
alles machen kannst, du blickst nicht durch.
Du blickst legit nicht durch in diesem Spiel,
wenn du anfängst.
Mit den neuen Skill Gems können wir unsere
Helden zu Wehrwölfen oder Wehrbeeren
machen, was im Kampf neue Möglichkeiten
eröffnet und uns entsprechende Boni
wie Geschwindigkeit oder Widerstandskraft
gibt. Path of Exile
hat ein außerordentlich umfangreiches
Skillsystem. Und das ist doch nicht mal alles.
Also das, was ihr hier seht,
das ist der
Standard. Das ist der Standard
Skillbaum. Aber
es gibt jetzt neue
Items, mit denen kann man
den Skillbaum an festen
Knoten erweitern. Also sprich, du hast
dann
zum Beispiel hier hast du so einen Sockel,
du kannst in den Skillbaum quasi
hier was reinsockeln,
was dann den Skillbaum weiter
erweitert. Hier oben gibt es beispielsweise
Feuerskills und den kannst du
dann erweitern um weitere Feuerskills.
Die kannst du aber nur freischalten,
indem du quasi deinen Skillbaum
weitersockelst und so. Das ist echt,
du blickst legit nicht durch, wenn du neu
anfängst.
... umfangreiches
Skillsystem. Auch das wurde
für den zweiten Teil angepackt. Keine
Sorge an die Veteranen. Es bleibt
riesig. Neben ein paar Quality of Life
Verbesserungen, zum Beispiel, kann man
jetzt keine falschen Gems mehr platzieren,
sie passen einfach nicht mehr in die Socke.
Soll der Skillbaum insgesamt das Monster
bleiben?
Ich überlege gerade, wie man falsche Gems
platzieren. Wie konnte man falsche
Gems? Was ist denn falsches Gem?
Zumal du es jederzeit wieder rausnehmen kannst.
...
Passive Building?
Oh, hab ich net installiert.
Dann...
kann ich's euch nicht zeigen.
...Management der Fähigkeiten über die Gems.
Kurz gesagt, in Zukunft ist es
einfacher aktive Fähigkeiten und Zauber
zu verbessern. Im Detail heißt das,
dass wir unsere Support Gems zum Verbessern
der Spezialattacken und Zauber jetzt direkt
in die entsprechenden Skill Gems einsetzen,
statt in die Ausrüstung.
Wie schon gesagt, könnt ihr in diese Socke...
Wait a minute.
Ich setz jetzt in
Gems weitere
Gems ein. Hab ich das richtig verstanden.
Das heißt, ich kann ja noch mehr
OP Sachen bauen, weil ich da noch
drei zusätzliche Sockel frei habe
oder so. Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
...einsetzen, die dort keinen Effekt haben.
Außerdem können wir so in Zukunft
theoretisch alle unsere Fähigkeiten
über die höchstmögliche Anzahl an Verbindungen
aufwerten. Bisher waren es ja
maximal zwei, nämlich Rüstung und Zweihänder.
In unserer ersten Preview zu Path of Exile 2
gehen wir noch etwas mehr auf die
angekündigten Änderungen des Spiels ein.
Den Link zum Video findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung.
Und es gab noch
eine ziemlich unscheinbare kleine
Änderung, die bei den Fans aber...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Jedes Item kann jetzt
sechs Sockel haben. Hab ich das richtig gehört?
Okay. Das wird ja
noch OPer alles.
...kein Quality of Life Feature, aber eben
eines, um das die Spielerinnen und Spieler
schon seit Jahren bitten, dauerhaft
sichtbare Darstellungen der verbleibenden
Lebenspunkte in Bosskämpfen.
Ah, okay.
Dass man nicht drüber muss.
Ja, die wird genau so schlecht sein, wie die erste.
Aber, aber, aber... Okay, die Charakterklassen
sind genau die gleichen, ne?
Templar, Witch, äh, äh...
Marauder? Ich vergesse immer, wie das Ding heißt.
Hab ich nie gespielt.
Äh, nee, Moment, das ist Witch. Witch?
Witch?
Eh, Sion. Sion ist das. Das ist Sion. Das ist
eine Witch. Das ist ein Ranger, das ist ein Tourist
und das ist... Was ist denn das? Shadow, oder?
Ja. Okay, hat sich nichts
geändert dran.
Huge Animation!
Ist doch, ist doch schlecht gewesen.
Die Aufgabe in Path of Exile 2
über die übliche Rettung der Welt hinaus ist,
verraten die Entwickler noch nicht.
Sicher wissen wir bisher, dass wir uns zuerst
den Weg zu unserem neuen Hub einer
Karawane in der Wüste frei kämpfen müssen.
Danach geht die Geschichte nicht linear
weiter. Stattdessen bietet die
Karawane... Okay, ich sag euch jetzt mal, was
passieren wird.
Ich sag euch jetzt mal, was passieren wird.
Und zwar, die ganzen, äh,
ich denk jetzt mal Pros,
ja, also Leute, die gut in dem Spiel sind,
äh, die werden wahrscheinlich
nach wie vor, weil das Endgame ist ja das Gleiche,
ja, also zwischen Path of Exile,
zwischen der 1er Kampagne und der 2er Kampagne,
die werden wahrscheinlich die 1er Kampagne
weiterspielen, weil du da in, äh,
keine Ahnung, wenn du richtig, wenn du schnell bist,
in 4-5 Stunden durch bist, also wenn du richtig schnell bist,
ich weiß, der Speedrun recordet sich
über 2,5 Stunden, aber das ist ein Witz, ich brauche,
ich brauche 9 Stunden oder irgendwie so, aber okay,
ähm, und das ist glaube ich auch schon relativ,
relativ zackig, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich das
letzte Mal gebraucht habe. Die werden
wahrscheinlich einfach die 1er Kampagne
durchrushen und gut ist,
es sei denn die 2er Kampagne ist irgendwie aus irgendwelchen
Gründen lukrativer, weil das Endgame ist ja das
Gleiche, das heißt, wie man dahin kommt ist erstmal egal.
Neue Mobilität. Uns werden 4 verschiedene Quests angeboten, aus denen wir wählen können,
wie das Spiel weitergehen soll.
Wenn wir festgelegt haben, welche Quests wir
verfolgen wollen, wird die Karabane dort Halt machen
und wir können zu unserem Abenteuer aufrechnen.
Okay, wenn die neue kürzer ist, dann wird die gespielt.
Darüber, ob man
den ersten Teil der Geschichte gespielt haben muss,
um die Story der neuen Kampagne zu verstehen,
lässt sich streiten. Das hatte keine Story,
das Game. Special Effects,
Kampagnen-Story, die war so dumm.
Die gab's eigentlich gar nicht.
Also doch, ich weiß, die gab's,
aber die war so konfus
und man hat richtig
gemerkt, die haben angefangen
mit einer Idee für 3 Akte,
das haben sie dann weiter ausgebaut
und dann haben sie nochmal was obendrauf gebaut,
das passt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen
und also für die Story
spielt das, spielt glaube ich, echt keiner.
Ja, genau.
Atlas-Stell.
Ja.
Das war klar, dass es so kommt, ja.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal,
das machen die auch,
um riesen Shitstorms vorzubauen.
Ich stelle euch mal vor, da gibt's Leute,
die haben da 1000 Euro drin ausgegeben
und das kannst du einfach quasi in mehr oder weniger
gleichen Spielern Kram nicht mehr verwenden.
Die werden ausgerastet.
So ungefähr wie bei FIFA, ja.
Aber in FIFA weißt du,
dass du dich da drauf einlässt.
Bam.
Garantiert.
Genau.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du kannst wahrscheinlich
im Hauptmenü das anklicken oder nach dem Charakter
erstellen oder was auch immer, also
das wird ein Spiel bleiben.
Schinke Kuro 2.
21 Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja.
Muss ich mal kurz lachen.
Wolcen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt noch Spieler hat.
Ja.
Das Game ruckelt, as fuck.
Also ohne Scheiß,
Pass of Exile schafft's,
was andere Spiele nicht schaffen, bei meinem Rechner.
Also, natürlich,
man kann alle Spiele so hochstellen,
dass es ruckelt, ja. Aber Pass of Exile
läuft superflüssig und auf einmal hast du
Frametrops runter auf 5 FPS,
das stottert dann kurz so, als läuft
irgendwie ein Garbage-Collector im Hintergrund oder so
und nach, keine Ahnung, 3, 4 Sekunden
ist dann wieder superflüssig. Also,
ich weiß nicht, was die da machen.
Cryptominer.
Das stimmt.
Die Animationen sehen tatsächlich besser aus.
Genau.
Das ist das,
dieses Bild ist,
ich weiß nicht, ob man das aktuell noch spielt.
Letzte Liga, wo ich gespielt habe, war das voll angesagt.
Das musstest du,
dieses Bild, ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt,
das musstest du dann sogar spielen
mit einem Skin-Mod, also mit einem Mod,
was diese Bälle anstatt
hier klühende Feuerbälle
hat, das da so dunkle Bälle draus gemacht.
Sonst hat es zu sehr
geleckt. Volatile, genau.
Das hat zu sehr geleckt, man musste da quasi
ein Skin-Mod reinmachen.
Sonst war das nicht spielbar. Und ganz ehrlich,
das ist eines der größten Probleme,
die ich in Pass of Exile und vor allem auch im Endgame sehe,
also im Prinzip schon,
seit ich das Spiel
oder seit ich es widerspiele,
umso weiter du im Endgame
kommst und
kommst noch ein bisschen auf das Bild an,
im Prinzip, du siehst nichts,
was passiert.
Du rennst einfach in
upperm Speed und um dich
explodiert alles drum herum.
Ja, also
und das
geht jetzt noch halbwegs, was man
hier sieht.
Aber du blickst eigentlich
nix mehr.
Aber eine der wichtigsten,
wenn nicht die wichtigste Frage,
wenn über ein neues Spiel gesprochen wird,
ist natürlich, wann es denn
fertig ist. Dazu weiß
Grinding Gear Games leider noch keine Antwort.
Ursprünglich hätte bereits Ende
2020 ein Vita zu Pass of Exile 2
statt. Genau, das hatte ich auch noch im Eventer-Kopf.
Nun musste das Studio etwas zurück rudern.
In einem Interview mit Gamespot sagt Chris Wilson,
dass man 2021 nicht mehr damit
rechnen dürfe. Grund dafür
ist zum einen die weltweite Pandemie,
die die Entwicklung zahlreicher Spieler
ausgebremst hat. Die Arbeit am neuen Spiel
ging einfach langsamer voran, als es sich
die Angestellten wünschen würden.
Ein weiterer Grund für die Verzögerung war, dass
bevor mit voller Power an Path of Exile 2
gearbeitet werden sollte, noch eine
normale, vollwertige Erweiterung
für den ersten Teil anstand.
Auch das neue Aadon wurde ja um ein paar Wochen
geschoben mit der Begründung, dass man sich das
Release-Fenster nicht mit Cyberpunk teilen
wolle. Das war, by the way,
das war einfach nur Ausrede, ne?
Die waren einfach noch nicht so weit.
Die waren eigentlich auch ganz froh, dass sie das verschieben konnten damals.
Das fand ich auch geil, diese
Aussage nach dem Motto. Die haben ja nicht
geschrieben, sie wollen sich das Release-Fenster nicht mit
Cyberpunk teilen. Das ist ja nur die halbe
Wahrheit. Die haben quasi geschrieben,
sie wollen Spieler, so sinngemäß,
sie wollen Spieler nicht in den, also
sie haben sich als die Superguten hingestellt, sie wollen
den Spieler nicht in den Konflikt bringen,
zwischen PoE und
Cyberpunk wählen zu müssen und
deswegen verschieben sie das, dass die
Spieler, die waren einfach nur
nicht so weit.
Erdlas rechtzeitig veröffentlichen
zu können, wurde das Team, das bereits an
der Fortsetzung gearbeitet hatte, vom Projekt
abgezogen, um die Entwicklung zu schützen.
Kurz gesagt, Path of Exile 2
ist noch nicht in greifbarer Nähe.
Grinding Gear Games rechnet frühestens
2022 mit einer ersten Beta.
Bis wir selbst dran dürfen, müssen wir uns
also noch etwas gedulden.
Was können wir also noch
Hey, das ist doch, ey, das ist doch die
gleiche Sprecherin von, von, von,
von dem, von, von der einen,
ähm,
äh, wie heißen diese,
wie heißen die, die in dem Singleplayer?
Von diesen Beschwerertypen aus dem Singleplayer?
Ist doch die gleiche Sprecherin, oder?
Bei der ersten Beta, bis wir selbst
dran dürfen, müssen wir uns also noch etwas
gedulden. Das ist
original die gleiche Sprecherin.
Was können wir also noch bis dahin
Okay, vielleicht ist auch der gleiche Character, kann ja sein.
In erster Linie können Fans
natürlich weiterhin Path of Exile
spielen. Wie früher im Video schon gesagt,
sollen die beiden Spiele sich das Endgame teilen.
Alle Fortschritte, die ihr jetzt
also im ersten Teil noch erspielt und auch
Mikrotransaktionen, die ihr tätigt, bleiben
euch in Path of Exile 2 erhalten.
Anfang des Jahres erschien mit
Echoes of the Atlas eine neue Erweiterung, die
wieder eine ganze Menge neue Inhalte ins Spiel
gebracht hat und wie jede neue Season,
führt auch die Ultimatum-Liga eine
spannende neue Liga-Mechanik ein.
Dieses Mal fordert der Trial Master,
ein Diener des Chaos-Gottes, euch zu
Arena-Campen heraus und verspricht für
Führerische Belohnungen.
Wenn wir die Gefechte
bestritten haben, stellt er uns vor das
namensgebende Ultimatum.
Entweder wir akzeptieren den Preis
oder wir stellen uns im Kampf immer
schwierigeren Herausforderungen, um
zusätzlichen Loot zu gewinnen. Im Endgame
betreten wir gelegentlich das Reich des
Trial Masters und können dort nochmal
schwierige Kämpfe bestreiten, für die wir
allerdings zuerst ein Opfer bringen müssen.
Wenn wir die Prüfung meistern, bekommen wir
den Einsatz doppelt zurück, wenn wir es aber
nicht schaffen, sind sowohl Einsatz als
auch zusätzlicher Loot weg.
Zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
Ich opfere einfach den Chat. Easy Loot.
In Path of Exile 2 wurde auch ein
Mobile-Ableger der Serie angekündigt.
Von dem haben wir allerdings seitdem
nichts Neues gehört.
Da der auch komplett im eigenen Studio
entwickelt werden soll und man sich dort
jetzt auf Path of Exile 2 konzentrieren will,
sieht es nicht danach aus, als würden wir
dieses Game in nächster Zeit sehen.
Das war's mit unserem kleinen Ausblick auf
Path of Exile 2. Wie schaut's bei euch aus?
Ärgert ihr euch über die Verschiebung
oder seid ihr erstmal noch eine Weile mit den
Inhalten des ersten Teils glücklich? Ich freue mich
auf eure Meinung. Wenn euch das Video gefallen...
Also eins machen die wirklich gut bei Path of Exile.
Die schaffen es über Jahre
lang ihr Game für Dauercrinder
attraktiv zu halten.
Klar ist es so, die Leute, die das Spiel
also gerade auch die größeren Streamer,
die das Spiel irgendwie schon seit 5 Jahren
oder so spielen, das kann man 2013 oder sonst
wie raus, seit 7 Jahren oder sonst wie spielen,
du merkst das immer richtig.
Eine neue Liga fängt an, die Typen
grinden 24-7 für 1-2 Wochen
und dann flacht's ab und sie spielen
wieder anderes Zeug. Aber nicht dazu
trotz schaffen die das, dass die Leute dabei
bleiben und bei jeder Liga wieder am Start sind.
Das muss Dauers mal schaffen und das schaffen die nur,
weil die
es zumindest meisten schaffen, halbwegs
interessante Inhalte irgendwie noch in das
Spiel zu integrieren, die es so vorher
nicht gegeben hat. Leider
werfen die halt auch kaum Inhalte raus.
So, oder was heißt leider?
Kann man sich jetzt drüber schreiben, ob
das gut oder schlecht
ist. Zumindest hast du
jetzt halt keine Ahnung wievielte
Liga das ist. Ich sag jetzt einfach mal die 15. Liga.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Die haben jetzt quasi von 15
Liga, also 15
Leagues, die sie gestartet haben, im Prinzip
ist in ihrer Leader Reset
haben die quasi die Mechanics
zum größten Teil noch drinne. Das heißt du hast jetzt
gesammelten Endgame
Content und Endgame Currency,
Endgame Items
drinne von
Leaders, die quasi
zwei Jahre her sind
und die du eigentlich
gar nicht mal wirklich brauchst,
außer vielleicht alle 100 Maps mal
eine Bonus Map zu machen damit. Also es
ist äußerst undurchsichtig, ja.
Und dann haben sie noch solche Sachen drinne
wie
dieses Syndicate Board, was auch
erstmal so eine Wissenschaft für sich ist, wo du keine
Ahnung hast was Sache ist, ja.
Wo du weh nun wie dann miteinander verknüpfen
musst und solche Dinge. Ey, das ist echt
Kegwade. Also das Spiel ist
echt eines der komplexesten Games, die
ich kenne in dieser Richtung, ja.
Also das ist wirklich
Metamorph. Ne, ich glaube
Metamorph ist nicht komplett rausgeflogen.
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube
du kannst heute, du kannst immer noch
Metamorph Teile finden.
Halt nicht mehr so oft
wie in der Metamorph League.
Ich glaub du kannst immer noch Metamorph
Teile droppen, aber das ist halt recht selten und
dementsprechend kannst du irgendwie alle Schaltjahre
mal so ein Metamorph
Kampf machen.
Das ist schon äußerst
komplex das ganze.
Aber ich sehs übrigens umgedreht, ne.
Nicht Kampfansage an Diablo 4. Ich sehs
eher umgedreht. Diablo 4
müsste eigentlich eher die Kampfansage an
Path of Exile sein, weil Path of Exile ist einfach das Ding
wo du rankommen musst aktuell.
Nicht umgedreht. Das da Diablo
irgendwie so die Reference
wäre, ist meiner Meinung nach schon vorbei.
Schon lange vorbei.
Green Style, 5 Monate,
Dankeschön. Für
den Massive Sub.
Ok, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Leute, wollen wir uns noch ne Runde kommen?
Wir gucken uns noch ne Runde Battlefield an. Ich guck immer gern
Battlefield 3 Gameplays, ich weiß Boomer
Game und so. Boomer
Clap. Warum gibt's eigentlich die Kombination
aus Boomer Clap nicht?
Es gibt Easy Clap, aber es gibt kein Boomer
Clap.
Aber im Chat müsste das funktionieren.
Boomer Clap, ja das funktioniert.
Ok.
Wir gucken uns ne Runde Battlefield 3 an.
Vor allem Infanterie
Plays. Und by the way, ich mach den
absichtlich nicht so laut, weil er sagt
jedes Mal das gleiche und ich laber eh drüber.
Der Sound von dem Game ist auch immer noch
übelst nice.
Null?
Wie viel? Alter, what the fuck?
Wie viel hat der da mit seiner
Granate gekillt grad?
Da muss ja der ganze Gegner, da muss ja
da muss ja, da muss ja komplett alles
voll sein mit Gegnern.
Ich hab das ihm alt hinzugefügt.
Der hat bestimmt noch, ja ja, da ist bestimmt
noch ein C4 oder irgendwas in die Luft geflogen.
Es ist eine Konsole?
Das ist so eine
schlechte Auflösung.
Aber das sieht zu gut aus für
Konsole, es kann eigentlich nicht Konsole sein.
Aber das Movement und alles ist nicht Konsole.
Das ist Venice, oder?
Von der Farbe her.
Ist das Venice?
Ja, der Chat ist eindeutig Venice.
Ah nee, oben rechts steht's ja auch.
Oben rechts steht's ja auch.
Ja.
Moment.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das
jemand wirklich live erspielt hat.
Venice ist dead.
Moment, Moment.
Okay Leute, ich tippe auf
meist benutzter Server
5 Spieler.
Nee, Knoom, das neue Knoom hab ich ja nicht
angeguckt.
Drei.
Drei Spiele, Alter.
Massive.
Oder auch nicht Massive.
Ja, schon dead,
aber die haben es halt ein bisschen verkackt, ne?
Du kannst es nicht komplett
irgendwelchen random Server-Anbietern überlassen,
dass du was Sinnvolles hingestellt bekommst.
Die haben wirklich, die haben echt
guten,
wirklich,
die haben echt guten
Grundlage gelegt,
aber es hätte einfach, meiner Meinung nach,
es hätte eins, zwei
offizielle Server gebraucht.
Mit
sinnvollem Regelset,
die zeigen, was cooles geht, aber
was nicht zu weit
vom ursprünglichen Battlefield entfernt ist.
Zum Beispiel so Sachen wie
es soll kein Engineer-Waffen spielen und so.
Das ist eine richtig coole Idee gewesen.
Und es hätte eins, zwei
gute, offizielle, stabile Server
geben müssen, wo die Leute genau wissen,
ok, da kann ich mich einloggen,
da kann ich spielen, die brauchen
dementsprechend auch ein Moderationsteam,
die gucken, dass da keiner cheatet und sonst wo, und dann hätte das
sicherlich in Zukunft gehabt,
auch mit Spielern, aber du kannst auch
nicht zwei, drei Wochen
einen Memory-Leak drinnen lassen,
dass den Leuten nach drei Runden das Spiel abschmierten.
Das war so der Todesstoß, ja.
Auch jedes Video,
der Chat fragt, warum ich so leise mache.
Jetzt hab ich den Anfang gar nicht gesehen.
1490 in your face.
Das hier ist ja auch absolute
OP-Posy.
Das ist eins der besten Posys auf der ganze Map.
Da kannst du einfach reinhalten
und springen.
Oh, wegschneibt.
Da liegen sie.
Der Medic Train ist am Start, Leute.
Der Medic Train ist am Start.
Was ist das? M16 mit Schalldämpfer.
Also ganz ehrlich, dieses Feeling hatte
vielleicht noch Battlefield 4, aber danach
keins mehr.
Also dass du einfach so wirklich in der Mitte
der Scheiße bist, alles um dich in die Luft fliegt,
aber du kommst trotzdem irgendwie heil raus.
Das hatten die
letzten zwei
Teams einfach nicht mehr.
Erst mal schön da durchrennen
und jetzt sterben.
Und wegschneiden.
Das ist übrigens ein super Posy da oben.
Man muss über die...
Battlefield 3 Tipps
in 2021.
Man muss über die Rolltreppe,
die Seite, man kann trotzdem hier auf die Seite
hochrennen. Das ist viel besser als über die Rolltreppe
selbst rennen.
Oh, da stehen sie wieder.
Da stehen sie und lassen sich bashen,
Alter.
Ah, yes.
Moment, Moment, ist das
French?
Poggers?
Am spielen?
Ja, eindeutig.
Poggers.
Der Cand Bab forgot...
Ja, es wird Mist7 kennen,
aber ich nehm nur dيم!
Auch wenn ich noch生 Beetle.
Hallo
Osaka
María
Elena
benevolent
Sahara
Katsukura
3 Clips von Archer
Ah, Nosher TDM, was sonst?
Check out this clip for accuracy
The AEK 971
Die Schneiber Dudes
Die Schneiber Dudes, die einfach nichts anderes machen
Außer auf dem Turm zu geiern
So schlimm
In these close quarters conditions he just cannot be stopped
Ha, gut, der läuft eben auch mit dem Kopf voll ins Warnkreuz gerade
Brrrr
Er schreckt
What the... Hallo? Schneiber Dude, was los, Alter?
Ok, das 2 heute schon
Da ist der Headshot
Aber der Schneiber Dude auf der Erde schon wieder
Was ist hier los?
Ich bin überfordert mit dem Spiel
Was 10 Jahre alt ist
Oder sogar älter
Oder sogar älter, 11 Jahre alt ist
10,5 Jahre alt ist
Wann kam Battlefield 3 raus? 2010?
Nee, oder?
2011?
2010 war BC2, genau
Ach, hier ist stuff from Archer
Once again
Bam
Ha, ok, da bin ich lecker
Ho yeah
notable
Android, IOS, Windows, Linux
Metro, was sonst? Okay, wenn die restlichen Clips sind alle Metro
All of these enemy players failing to realize that they're being murdered and then for the rest of this clip
It's a mixture of his g3a3 and his secondary revolver accurate stuff once again from Archer on Metro
Egesprayt oh
Moment Moment, das war denn Headshot
What battlefield battlefield wait wait wait wait
Okay predicted calculated
Next up three clips from lackey the first is on the M40A5 with a really accurate BAM
In the ass
Or nice
In the ass wieder
Übrigens übrigens die könnten battlefield 3 heute nicht mehr rausbringen mit den mit den gleichen voice samples
Da hätte man sich heute schon drüber aufgeregt wie unkorrekt das wäre ich meine das sagen die sagen die soldaten sagen in battlefield 3
I get fucked in the ass over hier
Das mag sich vielleicht an an an echten gesprächen orientieren die da stattfinden aber das ist nicht politisch korrekt genug heute das ganze nicht mehr
rausbringen so war es in dem game das geht nicht
Next up we've got a clip from the M40A5
Next up we've got a clip from Metro the next two are actually going to be from Metro this one
He's once again playing aggressive
Schneiber
Das sieht man selten
Das sieht man echt selten in Battlefield 3
Aggressive iron side geschneide das kommt nicht oft vor
Das ist wir an dem moment ich dachte es ist den die wir mal gehorstet haben der der hieß aber anders
Bounty Bounty irgendwas ist der andere doch alter lassen die sich sprähen
Weil ich habe gesagt ab jetzt nur noch metro bis jetzt hat nicht recht okay noch ein metro
Moment der will den warum wollte der den gerade
Da ist er da ist er da ist er
Da ist er 11 Smoke Kills
Smokes in the ass geballert
Null besser als jede Shotgun easy
Das ist ja geil
Die lassen sich beschen du hast die gesagt nice
Die Eier
Guck mal so viele Kills mit dem smoke gemacht das und immer dass das smoke noch immer mehr munition hat
Das ist ja geil
Okay, also den 11 Smoke Kills Trick habe ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt in zehn jahre von diesem Game noch nicht gesehen
Geil aber die sind ja wieder planlos hoch zehn
Aber es muss so sein
Geil geiler Scheiß
Da ist die Moab
Klip Bounty Sentin ist ein really solid push getting a great angle starting out with this UMP 45
Und die does pick up um mit der um
Pointstreak that nearly hits 2000 der und ich habe letztens in das Spiel wieder reingeguckt
Er meint er hat irgendwie über 3000 oder über 3500 top sogar spielstunden battlefield also der crime ist schon eine weile
Operation metro rush
Ich habe tausend oder so alle plattformen zusammen
Oh nice
Ich bemm so sieht es aus bämm
Der der benutzt die richtige
richtige grammatikalische
Ausdrucksweise dafür wenn man gebäscht hat sagt man bämm
so wie bruce lee
Ich bin es früher ich glaube den clip den clip kennt gar keiner mehr bämm wie bruce lee
Ich weiß boomer memes
Rentner memes, ja ja ich weiß
Aber immer noch besser als 90 prozent aller tick tock memes true lul weh
Aber die werden schon wieder heftig zerstört wenn ihr jetzt noch eine granate
Hätte und die dahinten rein zu hauen das war natürlich poggers
Close originally
Close if
The final clip from tc bounty g3 next to charlie objective
Getting on kind of the last push towards the enemy players
It's their last flag if they don't hold this then the enemies will be back in their base
Okay
When you got like metro metro ist
Ziemlich spawn campy was das angeht
Silence g3
Oh, die lassen sich wieder bächen ist richtig in ihr face alter bän so zu sagen nice
Die werden wieder zerstört
Okay, es war klar dass jetzt hinten rauskommen
Backrage
Sachte sagt der commentator sonst immer wenn irgendwie sowas passiert backrage weiß auch nicht ich hab ich verwende das wort backrage eigentlich sonst nie aber
Irgendwie mag der das wort backrage
Eats noob bashing naja man darf nicht vergessen er ist es natürlich sonst kriegt man das natürlich nicht hin
Aber man darf nicht vergessen das game ist zehn jahre alt also die leute hatten genug chancen bisschen zu üben
Als aus an den maßes nicht also
Beste waffe ich weiß objektiv betracht 16 die beste aber ich mag die am liebsten
M4 16 auch genau dieses set up kautra visier
Efe bärer
Bämmer bäbäm
Und mit geht mit geht hier
Ich habe damals erst durch dich gelernt wie man den recoil der waffen kontrolliert ja in meinen battlefield 3 ist es ja auch ziemlich easy
ne gerade m16 beziehungsweise
M4 m4 16 beide sind easy du musst einfach nur ungefähr so in der geschwindigkeit runterziehen das war es das ist alles
Im game wirklich nicht so nah nicht mehr und m16 ist sogar richtig nice zu burst feiern also schnelle burst also die
wenn du quasi 16
So in der richtung quasi
Tja leider so viele metro clips battlefield 3 oder soviel nice maps ich würde gerne auch ein bisschen andere maps sehen aber gut
Muss das nehmen was du kriegst zumal du halt nicht auf den meisten anderen maps spielen kannst
Deswegen fand ich die ganzen venice server cool die hatten auch andere in der rotation drin leider haben sie es verkackt
Jetzt schreckt
Er da hin na gut er ist über die treppe hochgelaufen
Ja das passiert passiert mir auch öfters
Was würde man wenn es verschissen von wenn es seite her gar nicht mal so viel man hat halt verschissen dass man
Man hat nicht sonderlich gut mit den leuten kommuniziert und
Meiner meinung nach was total versäumt wurde ist dass man 1 2 3
wirkliche
Stable server mit sinnigem rule set angeboten hat also quasi dass man 2 oder 3 wirklich offizielle oder soweit es offiziell ist
Offizielle server anbietet die eben den rule set haben was nah an battlefield 3 dran ist aber was coole neue sachen zeigt wo die leute
Halt sagen hey da weiß ich worauf ich mich einlasse du hattest ja nur custom server von anfang an komplett
Teilweise custom server wurde dir gedanken machen muss das ob die owner nicht selber cheaten und so was du hättest du hättest drei server machen müssen
Oder zwei ein conquest ein rush gute rotation
gute settings
Coole sachen wie zum beispiel das medics engineer waffen verwenden können und so was wo man wo man auch sieht hey das ist
Coole neuigkeiten die vorteil haben gegenüber vanilla zu spielen besser netcode
Farbfilter suppression und sonst wie und das hat sie den leuten bereitstellen müssen gut moderiert dass das hätte auch erfolg langfristig gehabt
Ist das jetzt dead ja ziemlich mal gucken also was die als also was als nächstes rauskommt ist er deshalb ist er
Der battlefield 3 reality mod der wird halt so mit dem normalen battlefield 3 game play gar nicht so viel zu tun haben mal gucken
Und ansonsten mal schauen was passiert ansonsten ist es ziemlich dead
Ja ist echt ist extrem schade weil das game sich besser gespielt hat
Also es hat sich ein bisschen komisch an komisch angefühlt erst mal mit höherer tick rate und und
Ja also besser hit rack du hast halt auch manchmal durchgeschossen sowas es war nicht perfekt aber es hat sich insgesamt finde ich doch besser
gespielt und weniger
Drei sekunden später kippt einer um wie vanilla
Die katze die katze hier dieses live live cam von der katze
Ok im prinzip das ist halt das was
Was bisschen doof ist das gibt im prinzip 90 prozent die granate macht unter ok macht doch kein damage unterm zug es gibt halt
90 prozent metro und norscher tdm
Also metro entweder konfest rush oder halt norscher tdm es gibt halt auch noch viele coole anderen sachen die man spielen kann
Aber gut ich will man nicht ich will mich jetzt mal nicht ich will man nicht so sein ich meine spiel ist zehn jahre alt
Es ist cool dass es überhaupt noch gespielt wird leider ist wenn es
Bäm bäbäbäm die lassen sich wieder weg klatschen
Ja spotting durch alles durch war halt europäisch
Metro was sonst? Schon wieder metro, Alter, please
Aber wenigstens meine andere waffe
Oh
Ja gut es wird halt auf den aufgang gerade ausgeschossen das kann mal vorkommen
Oh that's not cool
Hohohohohohohohohohohohh
Da Stehen sie immer aufgereiht
Ich hatte in dem letzten Video auch So ein Massive Cl tracing
Wo ichvy 3 gezeigtillions
wobei... acne
Essa
das war
Paten importing
Das war das Azubi Video
Da Hat Ich ab Anfang歪 klib Delie
Kommt es jetzt hier klar?
Ja, Herr Endpunkt hat den Foto.
Ja ja, Max.
Pass mal auf, jetzt, jetzt.
Ne, doch nicht?
Oh mein, wo kommt der Clip?
Oh, ist nicht da.
By the way, hat jemand das Video gesehen hier?
Ich hab letztens vor zwei Tagen oder so mit der Endpunkt telefoniert.
Geht's gut?
Ach, Big Stonks.
Ah, hier, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
Pass mal auf, jetzt kommt's.
Guck mal hier, ich stell's mich um die Ecke.
Er hat das Video gesehen, deswegen hat er sich gemeldet, ja.
Guck mal, ich stell's um die Ecke, BÄM, auf einmal fünf Gegner vor mir.
Ich so, ups.
Leider haben die sich umgedreht.
Ich konnte sie nicht alle wegsprayen.
Das wär aber auch geil gewesen, hätt ich die alle wegsprayen können.
Ah ja, egal, guck mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, ja, kann man machen.
Oh, wie sie sich wegsprayen lassen, Alter.
In your face, Alter.
Gesprüht und gebetet er.
Weiter.
Ist ja Wahnsinn, die rennen immer noch rein.
Deswegen jetzt übrigens, ich geh nie da runter, ich geh nie runter.
Ich geh immer in die Mittlere, in den Mittleren mit dem Waggon.
Die laufen immer noch durch, ich fass es nicht.
Haha, lull.
Kannst du so Döner-App machen, wo du so zeigst, wo günstiger Döner-Laden ist.
Wenn du ne geile API hast, wo man günstigst Döner-Laden für die Umgebung abfragen kann, mach ich das.
Döner-Champ.
Döner-Champ kommt dann.
Ich mein, wir haben jetzt schon den Preis-Champ gemacht, den Cool-Champ, den Watt-Champ.
Da fehlt eigentlich nur noch der Döner-Champ.
Ich hab jetzt übrigens mit diesem Mist auch auf der Arbeit angefangen.
Alle Sachen, die ich da jetzt angefangen hab zu basteln, sei es Skripts oder irgendwelche Programme, die heißen alle irgendwas mit Champ im Namen.
Diese Videos sind immer geil.
Lieferando einfach Preise auslesen ist nicht so einfach.
Keck Wade, die arme Katze, Alter.
Da gibt's ultra lustige Videos in der Richtung.
Ja, das ist auch geil.
Ich kann mir den Scheiß den ganzen Tag angucken, Alter.
Oh Mann.
Deswegen krieg ich wahrscheinlich auch so viel von diesen Schwachsinnens-Videos empfohlen.
Warum sollten wir uns Corona-News eigentlich ausblenden?
Ich mein, Chat.
Chat, warum sollten wir uns Corona-News durchlesen, wenn doch allgemein bekannt ist, dass es Corona gar nicht gibt?
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum YouTube da News überhaupt dazu anzeigt.
Ich gebe zu, war zu offensichtlich.
Ja, habt ihr recht.
Guck einfach nur in deine Abo-Box.
Ich hab außer meinem Fake-Account mich hier nicht eingeloggt.
Mit was für einem Schwachsinn haben wir uns hier dann mal eingeloggt.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Doom on a commercial kitchen appliance.
Ich hoffe, das ist nicht so langweilig.
What the fuck?
Ist das Windows 95?
Ist ja Pleading Edge Zeugs drinne.
Läuft sogar ziemlich gut.
Leaked.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas leaked ist.
Das ist irgendein Fake-Account, den wir uns mal für Fake-Sachen im Stream angelegt haben.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ist da Frasier am Start?
Ich glaube, ich hause jetzt den Frasier.
Geh fressen.
Gab es eigentlich schon viele News zu Battlefield 6?
Nicht wirklich.
Eigentlich gar keine News.
Doch gerade keine, die ich hausten kann.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Science and technology.
Wer ist in Science and Technology am Start auf Twitch, der Deutsch spricht?
Können wir da irgendjemanden hausten?
Moment.
Wie macht man jetzt hier nochmal die Filter auf German?
Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Ich kann Twitch nicht bedienen.
Hier.
German.
Aha.
Arduino Grill.
Excellent.
Betriebssystem in PHP.
MonkaS.
Also es gibt ja sicherlich Sachen, die kann man machen, aber die muss man nicht unbedingt machen.
Mümelmonster-TV.
Gibt es Cat?
Cat?
Gibt es Katzen-Streams?
Excellent, was ist das?
Nee.
Achso, ich dachte das ist eine Katze beißt sie nur in den Kissen.
Na gut, da haust ich keinen Leute.
Wir sehen uns, ich geh jetzt was füttern, ich hab mega Hunger.
Bis dann, vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Abend nochmal.
Machts gut, CU.